Die CD geht da weiter.
Das war die letzte Sendung.
Ist egal.
Was war das bitte, Tim?
Das war schon mal ein erstes Beispiel für diese Musik des C64, die in den C64 eingebauten Soundprozessor, den SID, das Sound Interface Device, genannt SID, gemacht wurde. Der C64 hatte einen dreistimmigen Miniatur-Synthesizer, der im Wesentlichen nichts anderes konnte als eine ADSR Kurve beschreiben.
Welches Spiel habe ich damit eigentlich gemeint?
Nicht die Blutgruppe des Programmierers.
Von einem Spiel, was heißt...
Keine Details, welcher Planet?
X-Kids.
X-Kids?
BMX-Kids, das war das mit den Fahrrädern.
Rob Hubbard, der einer von den bekannteren SID-Enthusiasten war.
Sie haben uns gefunden. Chaosradio 64 ist es hier und es geht heute Abend ausschließlich um den Commodore 64.
Nein, das ist schonmal völlig falsch.
Da habt ihr mich aber falsch gebrieft. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wer du bist, bevor du hier reinquatschst. Du heißt nämlich... wie heißt er denn?
Der Tom und ich quatsch immer rein.
Der Tom ist der, der reinquatscht. Falls ich dann heute Abend zu jemand anhört, wie die Leute, die nicht Schweinebratenbrötchen oder sowas, sondern Schweinsbrotbrötler essen, dann ist das der Harald, unser quasi Maskottchen aus Franken. Ich hab ja quasi Modo gesagt. Gleichsam Maskottchen. Ja und Tim eben. Tim ist der, der ab und zu mal in der Villa anruft, wo dann Frauen, Frauen am Telefon sagen, Ah, Tim. Ja, das ist Tim. Das hat sich nachhaltig gefehlt. Das hat mich nicht nachhaltig geprägt. Das hat mich unglaublich erschüttert.
Okay, nächstes Mal stehst du später auf.
Fangen wir doch mal an. Fangen du doch mal an.
Soll ich noch mal was erklären?
Erklär mir mal. Du bist unerklärlich. Guck mal, der zirpt. Ist das nicht geil? Also irgendwie der durchschnittliche Home Computer Freak, kriegt dann halt schon ganze wirre Zuckungen, wenn er diese Musik hört. Hier im Chat gibt es auch schon ganz begeisterte, vielleicht auch weniger begeisterte Kommentare. Das weiß ich gar nicht so ganz genau. Das ist ja alles so grün auf schwarz.
Tim, wir haben noch nicht mal angefangen. Vergiss die Kommentare.
Aber...
Wir haben noch nicht angefangen.
Aber das ist halt schon mal eine ganz bemerkenswerte Eigenschaft. Du kannst mal die Musik einschalten, Tom.
Geht doch.
Eine bemerkenswerte Eigenschaft, die irgendwie mit diesem C64 Commodore Home Computer, Commodore 64 Home Computer aufkam, dass man auf einmal irgendwie eine bezahlbare Maschine auf dem Tisch hatte, die irgendwie mit einem einfachen Chip in der Lage war, irgendwie relativ fetzige Sounds vom Stapel zu brechen. Das war natürlich am Anfang, als die Maschine rauskam, alles noch gar nicht so elaboriert. Da bastelten die Leute halt erst mal rum. Und zwar dieses typische Piepen und Gequälke, was man so auch sonst so kennt.
Heute in der U-Bahn von Handys hört.
Und das wurde dann aber relativ bald schon sehr cool. Die Leute haben richtig verstanden, dass sie auf einmal eine voll programmierbare Synthesizer-Maschine haben. Der war natürlich beschränkt, hatte halt nur drei Stimmen. Bei jeder Stimme konnte man sozusagen einen Ton einstellen. Und das tat man, indem man einfach eine einfache Höhlkurve beschrieben hat, die sozusagen den Frequenzverlauf, die eigentliche Klangcharakteristik der Stimme eingestellt hat, über vier Parameter, ADSR, also Attack, Decay, Sustain, Release, also wie schnell geht der Anstieg, wie schnell fällt danach die Frequenz wieder ab, wie lange hält sie sich auf diesem Level und wie lange klingt sie dann aus, langes Release, langer Hall und all solche Sachen. Also relativ einfach zu verstehen. Und dann gab es noch irgendwelche Abstrusenmöglichkeiten. Der hatte doch noch Filter in irgendeiner Form. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, wir müssen gleich nochmal nachschlagen, weil wir haben ja das Fachmagazin. Und ja, dann kommt dann so eine Musik cross. Ist das jetzt eigentlich auch gerade?
Nee, das ist neueren Datums. Und soviel zum Thema Spannungskore. Ich würde sagen, es geht heute um die 64er. Aber nicht nur, das meinte ich vorhin, sondern auch um 20 Jahre Computer und was man mit den Dingern alles so machen kann. Das haben sie euch aber vorgestern erst überlegt, ne?
So geht das nicht. Also ich geh. Achso, ich muss noch alles abschalten.
Wieso ist es auf einmal so dunkel hier? Was willst du sagen?
Wir machen 20 Jahre Computer?
20 Jahre Computer und das Zeitgeschehen dazu. Also es ist ein bisschen eine Zeitreise. Es soll nicht nur um die Technik gehen, sondern auch, was man früher schon mit dem Computer machen könnte. Wir haben da eine Werbung dabei. Vom Jahre 1984 von Atari, die denen damals auch schon das Blau vom Himmel versprochen hat.
Ist die Werbung hörbar?
Die ist hörbar.
Na ja, gut. Wir werden alles über alles erklären. Außerdem haben wir noch ein paar Reiseberichte in der Tasche, denn wir waren gerade mal wieder aus Kempten in Holland, wo sich viele Hacker zusammenfanden. Das war lustig und feucht. Es gab auch noch andere Eindrücke. Und jetzt können wir auch mal wieder Musik.
Chaosradio 64, es geht heute nicht nur um den C64, sondern um die gesamte Geschichte aller Computer auf der ganzen Welt und im Universum, die jemals gebaut und auch nur gedacht wurden. Und Harald fängt jetzt mal an.
Ja, ich fang jetzt mal an, ein paar Details über den C64 zu erzählen. Was ist nun dieser C64? Wann ist er entstanden? Wie ist er entstanden? Wie viel hat er gekostet und so weiter? Also es ging im Endeffekt los im Januar 1982, wo Commodore den ersten C64 vorgestellt hat. Der hatte einen Listenpreis von 1.400 Mark. Insgesamt, bis zum Ende der Produktion 1992, wurden über 17 Millionen von diesen C64 Computern verkauft weltweit.
Gibt es irgendwelche Zahlen, wie viele davon noch in Betrieb sind?
Das kann man nur schätzen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass noch eine ganze Menge in Betrieb sind, weil da kann nicht so richtig viel dran kaputt gehen. Das ist irgendwie alles noch relativ robuste TTL-Technologie, ein Mainboard, alles übersichtlich, da kriegt man selber noch mal ein Biertkolben reingesteckt, wenn irgendwas brennt.
Ja, es gibt auch alle Projekte im Internet, wo man nachsehen kann und wo Anbauanleitungen beschrieben werden, wie man selbst einen C64 nachbauen kann aus handelsüblichen Bauteilen.
Ja, das ist Pipifax eigentlich.
Ja, sicher.
Nee, ist klar.
Kann ich auch.
Der ist irgendwie auch weltweit sehr verbreitet. Ich war vor ein paar Jahren mal in Afrika, irgendwo so ganz tief in der Pampa, wo eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Technologie ist. Und dann bin ich auf irgendeinen komischen Traveler-Lodge, da gibt es ja immer diese ganzen verspulten Europäer, die da irgendwie hängen bleiben und sich da irgendwie ihre Paradiese ausbauen. Und dann traf ich da halt irgendwie einen Deutschen, der da auch so einen Hostelbetrieb, und der berichtet mir dann gerade ganz freutestrahlen, dass er aus Deutschland sich irgendwie 10 C64 eingekauft hätte. Irgendwie so irgendwie erst mal rataratarata, was willst du hier irgendwie mit? So und dann macht er da mit einem Spielhalle. Ja, da hat er einfach die C64 hingestellt. Da gibt es tolle Spiele für irgendwie, läuft alles prima. Und dann hat er einfach einen Raum gemacht, das rein. Und das sind halt alles, in der Stadt hat er halt irgendwie noch nie jemand überhaupt einen Computer gesehen. Und der kam dann halt gleich mit C64 an. Das war ein großer Erfolg. Heftig.
Kann man damit eigentlich Internet machen?
Ähm, ja eigentlich nicht. Das ist eindeutig aus der Vorinternetzeit. Es gibt einzelne Versuche, wo Leute angefangen haben ein kleines alternatives Betriebssystem dafür zu implementieren, dass dann auch TCP-IP spricht und so. Aber was ernsthaft ist, das ist halt nie draus geworden.
Ich meine, der hatte 64 Kilo weit RAM. Na ja, das haben heute auch viele...
Grafikarte.
Datenpakete, diese mal so hin und her gehen. Irgendwie schon irgendwie Icons tragen heute schon so viel Last. Und irgendwie an MP3 ist da gar nichts dran zu denken. Da würdest du mal kurz einen hören können.
Wollt ihr das nicht sagen? Wir haben mal 30 Sekunden die Pesh Mode mit 4-Bit Sampling-Rate eingesammelt und dann richtig geschnitten digital und so geloopt. Und die meisten Leute haben gedacht, da ist ein Kassetten-Recorder dahinter. Da ist ein Computer und da kommt Musik raus mit Gesang. Das war nicht normal. Beides gehörte nicht zusammen. Und das war damals möglich mit 64 K.
Ja, 64 K ist vielleicht noch ein gutes Stichwort, dass man ein bisschen was über die technischen Daten zu dem C64 erzählen kann. Er hat also eine 6510 CPU, 64 Kilobyte RAM, hat 20 Kilobyte ROM, in dem das Betriebssystem untergebracht war. Für die Grafik gab es den sogenannten VIC, das ist der Graphikchip, den Commodore damals verbaut hat. Der kam eigentlich aus dem Glass-Terminal- und Spielekonsolenbereich und ist dann in den C64 eingebaut worden. Für den Sound haben wir eben den Sit-Chip. Dieser Sit-Chip, wie Tim vorhin schon erzählt hat, ist für diesen unglaublichen Sound für die damalige Zeit verantwortlich.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Eine nach halb elf.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
In der Nacht, da sinken die Temperaturen auf 12 bis 8 Grad. Morgen wird es dann heiter, heiter, ha! Und trocken bei Temperaturen um 23 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit dem heiteren Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
Der Einsatz deutscher Soldaten in Mazedonien hat begonnen. Die ersten Soldaten werden in der Nacht ins Kopje eintreffen. Der Bundestag stimmte am Abend mit großer Mehrheit für eine Beteiligung an der NATO-Mission. UN-Generalsekretär Anan hat am Abend den sofortigen Rückzug der israelischen Truppen aus den palästinensischen Gebieten gefordert. In einer Erklärung äußerte er sich tief bestürzt über die weitere Eskalation der Gewalt. Die Geschäftsfähigkeit der Bankgesellschaft Berlin ist wieder gesichert. Die Hauptversammlung beschloss am Abend die Erhöhung des Grundkapitals um 2, 2 Milliarden Euro. Eine entsprechende Zusicherung hatte der Berliner Senat gegeben, um die Bank vor der Schließung zu bewahren. Eine Verkehrsmeldung Art 10 südlicher Berliner Ring. Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dreieck Potsdam. Zwischen Rangstorf und Genshagen ist die linke Spur von einem defekten Fahrzeug geblockiert. Ehm, Erald? Ja bitte. Danke. Ich bin schockiert. Frank Steffel. Peter Rex.
Klaus Woverei. Wer wird der nächste Bürgermeister? Fritz Reporter rücken den Kandidaten auf die Pelle. Morgen? Frank Steffel.
Ich hab gehört, aus 100 jungen Damen wird die schönste ausgewirkt.
Freitag? Klaus Woverei.
Ja natürlich, es war ein Jogging.
Montag? Gregor Gysi.
Es ist zwar wichtig zu träumen, aber das reicht mir nicht.
Immer bei den Radio-Fritzen am Nachmittag.
Wahlkampf in Berlin.
Und im Radio, Fritz.
Chaosradio 64 und Commodore 64 ist unser Thema. Erzähl mal was, ich könnte jetzt erzählen, dass ich früher mal damit gespielt habe, aber das will ja wieder keiner hören.
Wieso, was hast du denn gespielt?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, ich hab den ganzen Tag überlegt, was war das denn so? Und das war schon relativ spät in den 80ern, da gab's so ein Spiel, das hieß Vermehr, das war sehr geil. Da musstest du hauptsächlich irgendwie Entwicklungsländer ausbeuten.
Da musstest du sozusagen sein Reichtum vermehren oder?
Ja genau, das ging um diesen Maler Jan Vermehr.
Aha, und der hat halt alle ausgebeutet.
Nee, du musstest Bilder von ihm kaufen, das war irgendwie eine ganz absurde Geschichte.
Ein genotischen Spiel zu einem Maler auf einem Betriebssystem, das irgendwie nur 16 Farben kann.
Naja, war aber in bunt.
Naja, eben die 16 Farben, die der...
Ich bin selber mal wieder überrascht irgendwie, immer jetzt auch gerade, wo wir uns noch mal so ein bisschen durchs Netz geschleift haben, ob das Stichwort ist C64, auch gerade bei diesen ganzen Sit-Listings, ich finde auch tierisch viele Spiele, die ich nicht kannte. Das liegt bei mir jetzt irgendwie wohl im Wesentlichen daran, dass ich das auch irgendwann habe dann bleiben lassen, um nicht irgendwie mehr der Technik irgendwie zuzuwenden.
Ja, ich mein du hast zum Schluss ja auch wirklich solche Kisten gekriegt für 300 Mark mit 500 CDs, wo nur Spiele drauf waren, 500 Disketten, wo nur Spiele drauf waren. Das war ja irgendwie schon absurd.
Ja, kommt drauf an, wie man den Schluss definiert. Ja, aber es gibt also tatsächlich, gab es Zeiten, wo man für 20 Mark dann den C64 irgendwie bekommen konnte mit vielen, mit Floresten.
Da reden wir jetzt aber über den Anfang der 90er so, ne?
Das ist der Anfang der 90er, ja.
Am Ende der 80er hast du noch so 300 bezahlt.
Jetzt gehen die Preise wahrscheinlich schon wieder nach oben. Wir haben gar nicht geguckt irgendwie. Richtig, ja tatsächlich.
Bei eBay gucken wir es gut.
Es sind schon fast wieder Sammlerstücke und das treibt die Preise dann etwas nach oben.
Aber was halt sehr interessant war, war, irgendwie so mit dem C64 kam halt auch so eine ganz neue Jugendkultur auf. Also natürlich nicht nur mit dem C64, sondern auch mit allen anderen Home Computern, die Anfang der 80er Jahre so released wurden. Da hatte Atari seinen Atari 400, seinen Atari 800, die XL-Serie. Apple gab es natürlich auch schon eine Weile.
Irgendwie kamen dann auch Schneider, CPC und so.
Genau, dann kamen diese Japan-Klons, diese MP... Nee, M... Die haben sich ja gleich mit so einem... MSX genau. Die waren ja gleich ganz fett und wollten dann auch gleich so einen Standard haben.
Das Beos der 80er...
.durchgesetzt hat. Ich hab mir die Maschine nie genau angeschaut irgendwie. Es war immer ganz putzig, was da kam, aber so richtig interessiert hat es glaube ich keinen. Also zumindest nicht in Europa, das mag in Japan aus gewesen sein, ganz klar. Aber was halt neu war, man konnte halt ins Kaufhaus gehen und irgendwie neben Staubsaugern und Fernsehern und all diesen anderen Dingen, die es dort immer gibt, gab es dann halt auch Computer, die da so rumstanden. Und das Großartigste war, sie sollten ja verkauft werden, also wurden sie ja irgendwie ausgestellt. Und die Verkäufer hatten ja auch nicht den geringsten Schimmer, worum es sich bei diesen Geräten überhaupt handelt. Sie wussten, da kann man irgendwie einschalten, dann steht da irgendwie 38.911 BasicBytes Free. Und ja, dann kann man darauf rumtippen und vielleicht auch irgendwie 10 Print Hallo 20 Goto 10 drauf machen und so, aber dann war es das dann auch schon. Es gab natürlich dann auch schon so ein bisschen elaboriertere Verkäufer mit der Zeit, aber sie waren dann doch in der Regel selten. Das führte dann immer dazu, dass komplette Jugendhorden dann irgendwann diese Läden übernahmen. Ich hab das selber irgendwie bei so 2, 3, 4 Läden irgendwie in meiner Heimatstadt erlebt. Das wird dann irgendwie da so aufgeliefert und so, ah, da steht ja ein C64, geil, sogar eine Floppy, irgendwie, super. Und auch noch ein Zufall.
Vielleicht hat da einer eine dabei, eine Skette.
Das war natürlich dann der Brüller. Es hatte ja keiner eine. Kostet 1.400 Mark. Das war für den average Schüler ja auch nicht ohne weiteres irgendwie mal eben auszugeben. Floppy kostet dann noch mal das Gleiche.
Im Moment kosten sie übrigens bei eBay unter 100 Mark mit Floppy.
Wie viele Tage vor Ende der Auktion?
Das eine war morgen Mittag um 12, 12.30.
Das bedeutet ja aber nicht so viel. Das geht ja dann in 20 Sekunden schnell. Dann wird die Preise hoch. Aber ich denke auch, dass man für 200 Mark schon fett dabei sein kann. Das lohnt vielleicht sogar auch noch. Manches ist echt gut. Also so Jumping, Spielen oder Loadrunner.
Ich hab übrigens auch noch so ein Ding, wie hieß der denn? Da gab's von Texas Instruments gab's mal so eine komische Fiste. So was hab ich noch zu Hause schon. Kann man damit noch was anfangen? Will das einer kaufen?
Du hast einen TI994A?
Genau, ein TI994A, so hieß er.
Oh, mit der Klötzchen-Grafik.
Ja, genau.
Ja, irgendwie eine ganz...
Willst du den haben?
Eine ganz wilde Maschine, nein.
Schade.
Da musste man dann noch so ein Programmer-Modul reinstecken, damit man da überhaupt erst mal irgendwie Basic machen konnte.
Ja, das hab ich aber, das Basic-Modul hab ich und noch eins mit Autorennen. Also was damals Autorennen war.
Ja, Klotz links, Klotz rechts und zum Vorderen irgendwelche undivinierten Klötze, die irgendwie...
Pong mit Brummen.
Ich lese ja gerade im Chat, dass es Bemühungen gibt, den MP3-Stream irgendwie nochmal zum Laufen zu bringen.
Liebe Leute, falls ihr uns gerade über MP3 hört, dann habt ihr Halluzination.
Könnt ihr mir da mal im Chat mal kurz sagen, irgendwie... Ah ja, ok, also der Low-Quality-Stream sollte jetzt gehen. Schreibt mir hier einen Krüx. Ja, das hatten wir etwas vergessen. Aber wir sind ja alle ganz fleißig dabei. Dann gibt es ja noch so einen Ebay-Link, mal schauen, was dabei herauskommt. Ja, also das mit der Kaufhaus-Kaufhoch-Kultur, das war wirklich großartig. Weil da haben sich dann irgendwie das erste Mal so richtig die Szenen auch zusammengefunden. Das war halt so ein permanenter Reallive-Treff. Und meistens schaffte man es so einen Ort, so einen Kaufhaus-Ort. Na ja, da wurde so vier Wochen, sechs Wochen, da wurde massiv beackert. Und dann ging es der Geschäftsleitung irgendwann auf den Sack, dass halt irgendwie Tonnen von Nerds den ganzen Tag traubenartig dort waren und irgendwie ihre Spiele tauschten und rumtredeten und die ganze Zeit Dinge von sich gaben. Obwohl sie es halt auch, na ja, es war nicht so, dass sie generell jetzt irgendwie da mit dem Besen reingegangen werden und gesagt haben, geht mal raus hier irgendwie, ja Pickel, euch wollen wir nicht. Sondern sie waren auch sehr dankbar, weil dadurch natürlich auch Leute im Haus waren, die den Kunden auch erklären konnten, was diese Maschinen sind und warum man das haben will. Die haben permanent irgendwie Spiele reingemacht und die Verkäufer waren dann auch immer mit am Falschen und mit am Tauschen und waren immer ganz glücklich, dass sie irgendwie viele neue Programme bekommen haben. Es war so ein Geben und ein Nehmen, aber irgendwann gab es dann immer irgendwie Stress und dann zog man halt ins nächste Kaufhaus über.
Man muss halt auch sehen, dass der Real-Life-Aspekt dann noch wesentlich deutlicher oder wichtiger war, weil es gab noch kein Internet, auf die DFU-Szene war irgendwie noch eher in den Kinderschuhen. Nicht existent? Ja, man musste sich einfach tatsächlich treffen, um irgendetwas zu tauschen, um Spiele oder sonst irgendetwas auszutauschen, Erfahrungen auszutauschen und so weiter. Da war eben diese Szene dafür da.
Ist es just for the moment?
Chaosradio 64 und der C64 unser Thema. Wo waren wir denn stehen geblieben gerade?
Bei der Technik.
Bei der Technik? Harald, sagst du mal was über die Technik.
Ja gut, also wie ich schon angefangen hatte zu sprechen, ist es eine 6510 CPU, die ist kompatibel zu der 65002 CPU. Die lief mit, über den Daumen gepilet, einem Megahertz. Wir hatten 64 Kilobyte DRAM in dem Rechner, dazu kamen noch 512 Byte, ich spreche von Byte, keine Kilobyte SRAM, die als Color RAM für die Grafik gedient haben. ROM für das Betriebssystem hatten wir 20 Kilobyte, das waren drei Teile. 8 Kilobyte für das Basic, 8 Kilobyte für den sogenannten Kernel und 4 Kilobyte waren für das Character ROM, in dem die ganzen Zeichen, die im Textmodus dargestellt wurden, eben als Grafik abgespeichert waren, damit man die darstellen konnte.
Der hatte auch richtig Hi-Res, also was man damals halt unter Hi-Res verstand, also man konnte tatsächlich irgendwie im Monochrom-Modus jeden einzelnen Pixel ansteuern, was damals auch nicht normal war und er hatte dann auch noch einen Color-Modus, wo man in dieser Hi-Res...
Du konntest die Farbe hinterlegen, kreuzchenmäßig.
Ja, da hat man immer zwei Bit horizontal zusammengefasst und dem eine Farbe gegeben, damit das irgendwie im Speicher noch hingehauen hat. Also man konnte immer nur zwei Pixel nebeneinander irgendwie eine Farbe geben und nicht eben einzelnen, wie man das heutzutage gewohnt ist.
Ja, von dem Hi-Res, also die Auflösung, die man da hatte, war 320 x 200 Pixel im Maximum.
Hi-Res.
Ja, Hi-Res.
Andy-Res.
Ja, man muss sich's einfach vorstellen. Vielleicht noch zu diesem Grafikchip, wenn wir gerade bei der Grafik hängen, dieser Vic, der hat, wie gesagt, der kam aus der Spielekonsolen-Szene heraus und wurde dann in diesen Heimcomputer eingebaut. Und der hatte zum Beispiel Unterstützung für alle möglichen Dinge in Hardware, zum Beispiel Sprite-Grafiken. Sprite-Grafiken sind so kleine, naja, so Icon-große Grafiken, die sich irgendwo über den Bildschirm bewegen. Waren halt irgendwelche Spielmännchen, Jump'n'Run-Männchen und so weiter, die sich bewegt haben. Und dieser Grafikchip, der hatte diese Sprite-Funktionalität in der Hardware realisiert. Man konnte also bis zu acht von diesen Sprites haben, in der Hardware.
Weil sie einfarbig waren, oder?
Die waren tatsächlich auch, ja.
Dann konnten man die nicht alle einzeln einsteuern, aber es war...
Ja, dann hat man halt auch wieder diese zwei......Bits zusammengefasst...
Ja, da gab's immer wieder ein kleiner Einstellen. Man hat diese acht Sprites, und die Hardware konnte dann sogar erkennen, wenn Sprites miteinander kollidiert sind, oder wenn Sprites mit dem Hintergrund kollidiert sind. Also man musste das nicht in der Software alles berechnen, sondern man hat dann einfach von dem Grafikcheck eine Benachrichtigung bekommen. Ja, die zwei Sprites sind kollidiert, tu mal irgendwas, zeig eine Ante Grafik, dass da eine Kollision stattgefunden hat oder so.
Ja, damit war es einfach die perfekte Spielemaschine. Man konnte halt irgendwie tolle Musik machen, man konnte irgendwie halbwegs brauchbare, tolle Grafik machen, man hatte irgendwie die Möglichkeit zwei Joysticks anzuschließen. Und irgendwie, was wollte man denn eigentlich noch mehr? Und vor allem 64 Kilobyte RAM. Ein Wahnsinn. Das kriegen wir nie voll.
So, was soll man denn da reintun?
Gut, was hatten wir sonst noch an der Maschine? Es gab...
Dieser Vic hat sich übrigens auch um das RAM gekümmert. Das ist ein kleiner Nebeneffekt.
Er hat immer das RAM-Refresh gemacht. Richtig, der hat das Refresh vom RAM noch übernommen. Ja, ansonsten hatten wir noch einige Interfaces nach außen, zwei Joystick-Ports. Man gab dann später auch eine Maus, die man da anschließen konnte für diverse Programme. Wir hatten einen Serienport, über den unter anderem auch die Floppy oder Datasette, was man so hatte, angeschlossen wurde. Die Videoausgabe, man geht so davon aus, dass das jeder weiß, die wurde also über einen ganz normalen Composite-Videoausgang, den man im Fernsehen angeschlossen hat, realisiert.
Das war irgendwie super praktisch eigentlich, oder? Das möchte man eigentlich heute wieder haben.
Jaja, heute nennt man das Setup Box.
Genau, die Grafik bei den Setup Boxen ist ähnlich, stimmt.
Man konnte den auch geil programmieren, diesen Rechner. Man konnte halt irgendwie die Kiste einschalten und bumm, man war einfach sofort im Basic Interpreter. Man konnte also gleich die nächste Zeile, einfach 10 erste Programmzahle returnen und dann war das einfach eingegeben. Mehr war halt nicht nötig, war also so richtig irgendwie Hack Mode on. Der bootete irgendwie in zwei Sekunden, so und dann war irgendwie auch noch nicht mal eine Sekunde irgendwie und dann war er da, also klack, irgendwie kurzes, und dann hatte man schon den blinkenden Cursor vor der Nase. Das hat man heutzutage irgendwie auch nicht. Einziges Problem war, hast du den Schalter halt wieder in die andere Position gebracht und das Programm auch genauso schnell wieder weg.
Und davon, was ist das?
Und so mit Abspeichern und so, wer hatte schon eine Floppy-Disc, das musste man halt auf Datasette abspeichern.
Datasette hat auch, glaube ich, eine 150 Mark gekostet, oder? Ich meine, das Gerät hat nur 150 gekostet, aber das hat bestimmt irgendwann mal 150 gekostet.
Ja, das war nicht am Anfang. Ja, aber wenn man sagt, der booted schnell, wenn man Floppy oder Datasette sich ansieht, dann muss man aber auch wieder die Geschwindigkeit von diesen Geräten ansehen. Das war dann ebenso unendlich langsam.
Ja, das war unglaublich langsam. Das klang so geil auf einer Party. Hey, leg doch mal dieses Tape an.
Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz, Commodore 64 ist unser Thema und mir fallen jetzt so nach und nach immer so einzelne Worte an dich überhaupt nicht mehr irgendwo hinzuordnen kann. Und das eine, was mir eben eingefallen ist, war Poke. Erklär doch nochmal so süß, wie du mir das eben erklärt hast, was es war.
Mit Poke konntest du direkt einen Wert an eine bestimmte Speicheradresse in dem Computer hineinschreiben. Es war halt ein Befehl in diesem Basic, den du auch direkt so eingeben konntest. Und wenn du irgendwie Poke 53.281, 16 oder eins machst, dann war es Weiß. Genau. Also damit konntest du direkt die Farbe, die der Hintergrund hatte, bzw. dann noch 53.281, war dann die Farbe des Rahmens.
Genau.
Der sozusagen, wie so ein Passepartout irgendwie den Bildschirm schön in die Mitte gebracht hat, weil bei den Fernsehern ja so der Rand ist, das ist so eine diffuse Masse, da weiß man nicht so richtig, wie viel der Fernseher angezeigt hat, deswegen musste man auf einen relativ kleinen Bereich noch mal einschränken. Waren ja auch nur 320 Pixel.
Na immerhin.
Mal 240.
200.
Wollte ich ja nicht übertreiben jetzt.
Ja und woher hatte man dann diese Informationen, wie man an welche Speicheradresse irgendwie etwas schrieb? Da hat sich also dann, dadurch dass es diese programmiertechnischen Möglichkeiten gab, eben diese Szene irgendwo gebildet und es gab dann auch Organe dieser Szene, wie z.B. eben das 64er in Deutschland, das Computermagazin, das sich eben exklusiv den Commodore 64 verschrieben hat und in dem dann auch jedes Monat, wenn es veröffentlicht wurde, dann Listings drin standen und die man abtippen konnte.
Chexsum?
Ja oder Run ist auch noch so ein Magazin, hab ich erst vor ein paar Tagen wieder drin geplättert. Die hatten dann immer so Mädchen vorne drauf, so hübsche, so mit dem Rechner in der Hand. Ach echt? Sigi hat auch immer das Editorial geschrieben.
Was, die blonde Sigi kenn ich jetzt auch nicht.
Mit Foto für die Zielgruppe.
Echt? Nerdvorlage?
Nein.
Nicht mal in dem Alter.
Was der C64 wirklich auch geleistet hat, war irgendwie die Kids zu Programmieren zu machen. Die Schnittstelle, um überhaupt erst mal ein laufendes Programm zu bringen, die war einfach super einfach, super schnell und immer da und immer gleich. Und dadurch hat sich natürlich das Wissen auch gut verbreiten können. Das war einfach mal eine Norm dieser Rechner, die sich dann irgendwie fast alle gekauft haben. Und klar, eine Maschine hat immer irgendwelche Marken und Fehler und Sachen, die irgendwie auf anderen Computer besser sind. Aber es ist irgendwie der größte Wert, wenn irgendwie alle die gleiche Plattform haben. Man kriegt ja sogar auf dem PC was hin, obwohl diese Maschine irgendwie krank ist. Und beim C64 war es eben ganz genau so. Und dann, das ist auch noch wichtig, gab es so ein tolles Buch, von einem etwas umstrittenen Verlag namens Data-Backer. Das ist irgendwie so ein Spin-Off genau von dem Bäcker oder von dem Bruder von dem Bäcker, dem Auto-Bäcker, genau diesem riesigen Gebrauchtwagen-Händler. Und dann gab es halt Data-Backer. Und Data-Backer ist eigentlich relativ cool an die Sache herangegangen. Die haben sich einfach Freaks genommen, die irgendwie Bescheid wisten. Und die haben einfach aufgeschrieben, was drin steht. Also gut, denkt man sich halt zunächst einmal ein normales Computer-Buch, wie es heute so viele gibt. Da gab es ein Buch, ein sehr frühes Buch. Das war glaube ich sogar das erste oder das zweite, was irgendwie rauskam. Das hieß 64 intern. Hier in diesem hübschen rot-weißen Einband irgendwie.
Bundeszentrale für die politische Bildung. Also die machen ihre Bücher immer noch in dem Layout. Ernsthaft, das sieht, also jetzt nicht in der Type, nicht in der Type innen, aber außen, das Layout außen von dem Buch. Das sieht heute noch genauso aus wie 64 intern. So ein Rahmen, der eigentlich, wenn er schwarz wäre, wäre es ja eine Traueranzeige.
Das DTP haben sie wahrscheinlich auch mit dem C64 gemacht und dann haben sie einfach einen Matrix-Drucker angeschlossen, einen FX80, wenn ich hier irgendwie den Font richtig interpretiere. Südlage.
Hey, Tim ist ein Font-Interpreter.
Ja cool, und dieses Buch besteht ungefähr zur Hälfte aus Erklärungen, wie so bestimmte Sachen funktionieren. So geschriebener Text. Und dann irgendwann weiter hinten, Kapitel 8.3 auf Seite 144 von 300, ist einfach nur Rom-Listing. Seitenweise einfach Zahlen. Hier steht zum Beispiel A238, 5441, D8, 52454, 5552.
Das war ein Moment, sagst du nicht?
Weil das ein etwas schwierigste Interpretieren war, war es halt auch noch komplett kommentiert. Das heißt, die Jungs haben sich die Mühe gemacht, das Rom, in dem halt das Betriebssystem dieses Computers irgendwie eingebaut war, das war halt komplett kommentiert. Die Jungs haben also im Prinzip so eine Art Open Source gemacht. Und das Buch haben sich natürlich dann auch alle gekauft. Und dann ging das irgendwie mit der Softwarequalität auch sprunghaft nach oben, insbesondere in Deutschland.
Ja, ich mein, man muss dann auch sehen, dass die Computer und insbesondere die C64 halt wirklich auch noch einfach zu verstehen waren. Die ganze Komplexität, die heutigen Maschinen, egal welches Herstellers oder welcher Architektur, sind einfach so komplex, dass man einfach gar nicht mehr so viel über die eigentliche Maschine verstehen kann, wie sie eben damals möglich war. Das alles so handelsübliche Teile, ganz einfache Dinge, keine komplizierten Caches und Cage Coherency und was weiß ich, was man heute alles in irgendwelchen Architekturen hat, das war alles total einfach. Jeder Jugendliche konnte hin und konnte das verstehen.
Wichtig war auch, dass die Platine so war, dass man mit einem normalen Lötkolben Sachen ran rausfasseln konnte. Richtig.
SMD war Fremdwort.
Schönen Abend. Hier ist das Chaos-Radio. Und zwar das Chaos-Radio Nr. 64 mit dem C64 als Thema. Ja, hast du wieder LSD geraubt?
Du kannst dich aus mit Drogen, was?
Ja, ich esse auch immer haschisch und spritze mir, was spritzt man sich denn garantiert nicht? Gras. Gras, ich spritze mir Gras.
Super.
Können wir jetzt wieder zum Thema kommen? Ich brauche mich ungern zum Löffel.
Wer hat angefangen?
Apropos Gras.
Apropos Gras, ihr wart hier nicht in Holland?
Ja, wir waren in Holland duschen. Duschen?
Wieso duschen? Ich dachte, da haben die Fahrräder und keine Duschen. Ja, das hatten wir auch gedacht. Aber es gab halt auch Duschen. Wir standen halt da von den drei, vier Tagen auf dem Acker ziemlich viel im Regen. Wir waren auf der Hell 2001, was halt ein relativ großes Hackertreffen ist in Holland.
Wie viele Leute waren da?
Da waren 3000 Leute irgendwie. Also es war richtig knüppeldick gefolgt. Es war ein großes Gelände, so ein Park, Teil der Universität in Twente. Oder der Universität Twente.
Ich wollte einfach sagen, dass wir das später sagen.
Auf jeden Fall waren wir da und das war irgendwie alles ganz toll. Wir wollen davon auch ein bisschen später erzählen. Und vor allem wollen wir irgendwie von dem Radioprogramm, das dort gelaufen ist, noch ein paar nette Interviews bringen, die das zuhören wert sind.
Ja, dann machen wir das zum Schluss der Sendung. Lass uns weiter über den C64 reden, weil das wollten wir eigentlich. Ich hab keinen C64. Er schenkt mir einen. Ich tausch meinen C64. Ich tausch meinen TI-99.
C64 war nicht nur im Westen, wo wir alle herkommen, ein begehrtes Gut, sondern natürlich auch im Osten. Es gab Leute, die in der Lage waren, sich durch die notwendigen Kontakte und Beziehungen oder Verwandte in den Besitz eines solchen Gerätes zu bringen. Es gab auch andere Computer, die verbreitet waren. Da bin ich allerdings kein Experte. Natürlich auch der ZX-Spektrum hatte einen gewissen Verbreitungsgrad. Der war auch noch billiger. Aber eben auch der Commodore 64.
Wie viele gab es da?
Im Osten.
Gibt es da Zahlen?
Keine Ahnung. Nö, auch noch nie.
Vielleicht ist ja irgendjemand offiziell ein ZX-Erhebung.
Darüber gab es ja C64, die DDR gespuckt worden. Ich kann es auch nicht einschätzen, aber vielleicht gibt es ja unter den Zuhörern Leute, die das einschätzen können und die irgendwie eine Einschätzung gehabt haben oder in der Lage waren, einen zu bekommen. Oder die vielleicht jemanden kannten, der einen gehabt hat oder die sozusagen gehackt oder programmiert haben.
Also falls Sie sachdienliche Hinweise geben können zum Thema C64 in der DDR. Sachdienliche Hinweise zum Thema C64 in der DDR unter der Telefonnummer hier.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Ich denke, du bist da wirklich einer billigen Propaganterlüge aufgesessen. Im Osten gab es keine Computers. Echt nicht?
Die sind gerade alle online mit 300 baut, deswegen könnt ihr nicht anrufen.
Die haben mir Mist erzählt. Belehrt uns eines besseren, ruft an, falls ihr tatsächlich irgendwie in Berührung mit einem C64 gekommen seid in der DDR oder jemanden kannte, der mit einem C64 in Berührung gekommen ist oder jemand, der jemanden kannte, der mit einem C64 kam.
Oder wenn ihr andere nützliche Erfahrungen oder irgendwie interessante Erfahrungen mit dem Commodore 64 gehabt habt.
Galt das jetzt für die DDR oder auch für die BRD?
Das galt jetzt für die Hörer.
Das galt für die Hörer, gut. Jetzt wüsstet ihr noch gerne, wo ihr anrufen sollt.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Weißt du, was ein Rasterzahlenintervot ist?
Äh, ist das so ein Ding, es sieht so ähnlich aus wie ein Lochblech, ne? Ich habe nicht die leiseste Ahnung, aber wir haben Anrufe. Also ich könnte mich aus dieser Nummer jetzt wirklich gut rausstiegen.
Ja, frag mal.
Ja, fragen wir mal.
Ob er weiß, was ein Rasterzahlenintervot ist.
Hallo, weißt du zufällig, was ein Rasterzahlen...
Rasterzahleninterrupt.
Nicht zum Ragget zu tun.
Da gibt es einfach einen Puls, und dann springt die Zeile einen runter. Und da kann man doch auch Interlace mit machen, oder? Man sieht ja nicht hoch, da konnten wir irgendwie einen Tricks mehr Farmen darstellen, nicht nur sechzehn.
Ich geh mal aufs Klo so lang.
Gleichzeitig im Bildschirmhintergrund.
Ich weiß nicht, die haben richtig Grafik mit 32 Farmen gemacht. Wer hat so Malprogramme, die haben das ausgenutzt.
Genau.
Konnte ich mich erinnern. Und ich konnte mich erinnern, als ich mal am DDR-Fernsehen hab ich ja mal gerne geguckt. Ich bin nämlich aus dem französischen Sektor hier in Berlin. Und da haben wir ja unter anderem das tolle französische TV mit dem Nachtsendung, mit den tollen, leicht bekleideten Frauen.
Aber du guckst Nachts TM3?
Nee, TV-C, also 50 hieß das irgendwie.
Ja, genau.
Ganz klasse, aber da gab es tolle Erotik.
Na gut, also wenn ich da nicht hingeguckt hab, dann hab ich über meinen TV in SETI geguckt. Und wenn ich da nicht hingeguckt hab, hab ich ja so aktuelle Kameras geguckt. Und da war irgendwie Krankenhaus, so Bericht, DDR, und ein neues Zustand der Technik. Und da ist dann so ein TV in SETI durchs Bild gewandert. Da haben sie irgendwelche, bisschen Herztöne mit analysiert oder so. Ja, ich schwör, ich schwör das. Nee, aber jedenfalls, die gab's von der DDR. Obwohl ich hab mir jetzt so ein KC 85R Dingsbums besorgt.
Was ist das?
Das Pendant der DDR zum C64.
Ach, die haben den selber gebaut.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht der C64. Das war der KC 85.
Das war halt ein Home Computer, der von Robotron gebaut wurde, der auch basic verstanden wurde.
Ach war das dieses Ding, wo keine Q-Wertz-Tastatur dran war, sondern das ABCDEFG, so durchgehend?
Nee, da konnte man eine ganz klasse Tastatur ranstecken. Soll ich die so, die war so ja ganz schnittig, strommig für mich.
Ach so, ich hab irgendwie im WDR Computer Club so was gesehen.
Wir hatten auch im Chaosradio eine Sendung vor, nicht da zu langer Zeit, wo es um alte DDR Technik ging.
Gab es nicht damals noch Programme im Radio übertragen, mit so...
Nee, das haben sie doch über das Fernsehsignal, oder?
Nein, in der DDR gab es das im Radio, habe ich auch schon gehört. Die haben also diese Datasetten genommen und haben die einfach abgespielt im Radio und haben so Programme verteilt.
Die Leute konnten alle, die am Tapedeck waren, aufs Radio. Ich hatte erst noch einen umgebauten Kassettenrekorder, da konnte man auch immer alles hören, aber da gab es doch Turbo Load, da ging alles doch nicht so schnell. Vorher war das auch am Anfang der Kassette, da musste man erst mal reinladen, Turbo Load, das war ein vielen Programme. Dann war so ein Spiel, das relativ groß war, das 200 Blöcke hatte, jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, wie groß so ein Block war, schlag mich tot, aber das Kette hatte wohl 170 Kilobyte, und da waren jede Menge Blocks drauf. Wie viel noch mal? 600 noch was oder sowas?
698.
Eigentlich waren das noch klasse Spiele, da gab es so Raid over Moskau, ganz schlimme initiierte Dinge.
Was hätten die gemacht, wenn die euch damit erwischt hätten, mit Raid over Moskau, wie du gerade den Kremlbomb bei dir hast?
So hat man seine Jugend verschwendet und da ist ja nichts draus geworden.
Was hast du denn um C64 gemacht?
Ich hab zum Beispiel meine Diplomarbeit zum Schluss mitgeschrieben, mit Textomart, war das nicht?
Databekker, 80 Zeichenmodus.
Das grenzt ja schon an Selbstkasteierung.
Doch, doch, das hat funktioniert. Und Grafiken hab ich danach in gedruckt, die hab ich mit Geos gemacht, mit so einem Geos Paint Programm, und dann in die Lücken drin gedruckt. Und für so eine FH-Arbeit hat so ein bisschen gereicht.
Aber programmierst du das?
Ja, das war klar, das war auch der Hit, weil da gab es ja Informatik in der Schule, und dann hatten wir so einen geilen Wengen, ein Wengen-Computer, einen Apple II oder so was. Und das war ja alles irgendwie nicht so, und wir hatten C64 zu Hause mit Bund und so, und Wahnsinn. Und dann haben wir dafür Programme geschrieben, und dann haben wir den erstmal mit in eine Schule geschleppt. Irgendjemand hat seinen Heim C64 mitgebracht, und dann gab es da tolle Noten für die Programme, weil nicht nur einfach irgendwie eine Zahl ausrechnet wurde, sondern vorher war noch das tolle Poke-Blinken, also die Poke-Zahlen wurden durchgepokt sozusagen, und der Rahmen hatte geblinkt und alles, und riesen Schriftzüge wanderten über dem Bildschirm, und man ließ sich alles so ziemlich einfach mit irgendwelchen Zeichengrafiken machen und so.
Also dann gab es da so...
Ja, gab es so Demos davor, und der war dann ziemlich beeindruckt, der Lehrer. Also wir sind jetzt wieder viel hinausgeschossen.
Ja, das war alles sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und im Moment brennt mir ein Amiga-Radio eine CD. Also funktioniert immer noch die Commodore-Scheiße. 80 Minuten, das dauert aber eine Weile. Na gut, Jungs.
Jens, danke für deinen Anruf.
Fährt euch, mach's gut.
So, wir haben einen.
Wir müssen nochmal nach den Rasterzahlen in der Rapp fragen.
Klasse Name, weißt du, was ein Rasterzahleninterrupt ist?
Oh nein.
Schadisch, weil er, du kommst aus dem Osten, hast einen C64 gehabt?
C64 nicht, also war ein ZX81, Spektrum damals.
Wann ist die 81 das Sendung?
Das war in der DDR, Holger?
Ja, richtig. Ja, also auch wild besorgen lassen, irgendwie, also Vater hat es in Kiemen besorgen lassen damals. Irgendwann an so einem lustigen Junos-Monitor dran, so ein russisches Modell. Und ja, ich sag mal, was eben auch gesagt wurde hier mit dem Überradio-Ausstrahlen, das lief damals irgendwie auf DT64. Da gab es so eine lustige Computersendung. Und ja, da wurden wirklich also, ich sag mal, für die scheinbar verbreiteten Plattformen, das war damals halt der C64 und eben auch der ZX81 und halt das Baugleiche Gerät, das war halt dieser KC8502 oder 03, also da haben sie den ZX81 nachgeschraubt bei Robotron und da wurden halt direkt diese Programme da irgendwie ausgestrahlt übers Rundfunk.
Weißt du noch, wie dieser Professor, war das nicht ein Professor, der das gemacht hat? Oder ein, war doch ein Universitätsprofessor, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr. Also ich weiß noch nicht mehr, wie die Sendung hieß, aber ich weiß, dass es das halt noch gab, so schön zum aufnehmen und so. Das machen wir jetzt auch gleich nochmal.
Das machen wir jetzt auch gleich nochmal. Genau.
Ja, und wie gesagt, also ich denke mal, DDR-verbreitet waren eigentlich die C64 und diese ZX81-Dirivate. Denke ich mal.
Also ein C64 ist meines Wissens nicht nachgebaut worden.
Nein, also das war diese krasse AC-Reihe, das waren ZX81-Prozessoren.
Das war der gleiche Prozessor wie ein ZX81, ein Z80-Prozessor.
Ja, nicht dieselben, sondern die gleichen. Sagen wir's mal so. Also irgendwie, weißte nicht, Robotron hat die weißte ich, irgendwie nachgefeilt da oder so.
Holger!
Aus Seife geschnitzt.
Holger, vielen Dank für diese Anregung. Wir haben noch einen. Thomas? Thomas Kentei, erzähl mal.
Ja, hallo, hier ist Thomas und ich hab euch grad gehört, ich muss jetzt mal ein super Konfiment machen. Ich bin gerade bei euch hier in der Gegend und ich höre seit drei Tagen Fritz und ich bin so begeistert.
Nichts, nichts.
Warte mal, jetzt versteh ich euch grad nicht so gut. Ne, ich komm aus Gera und wir haben halt nur so Kommerzcenter.
Ja, aber lass uns über den C64 und den Deutz.
Oder den Deutz, oder den Deutz.
Oder den Deutz, oder den Deutz. Auf jeden Fall, ich kann ein bisschen eine andere Geschichte erzählen. Also die haben zu Ostfalen die C64 immer im Intershop gekauft, bei 400 Mark und haben sie dann irgendwie über einen A und V, sprich An- und Verkauf, verschoben für 16.000 Ost. Und der Typ ist deswegen dann nochmal kurz vor der Wende für drei Jahre irgendwie verknackt worden. Und ja, das ist halt so meine Erinnerung an C64.
16.000 Ost?
Ja, ja, also 400 Ost kam, oder nee, 200 Ost kam, ich glaube, bei uns im Intershop, ja.
Also 200 West im Intershop. Also was hat der Rechner gekostet?
Also im Intershop kam er glaube 200 oder 400 Mark, ja.
In welchem Jahr?
Äh, 88, so 89, oder?
Ich kann nicht erinnern, dass er so viele Solzettate hat, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Auf jeden Fall, okay, egal wie viel er gekostet hat, also ich stand für 12.000 bis 16.000 bei uns im ANV und das ist halt kurz vor der Wende, es ist halt aufgeflogen, dass die die Teile da halt verschoben haben. Und das ist irgendwie ganz lustig, also irgendwie C64 hat halt für mich eine andere Erinnerung irgendwie, weil der Typ ist richtig in den Knast gegangen deswegen und also es war alles sehr heftig.
Aber es ist richtig losgeworden.
Aber was war das Vergehen? Also ich mein, weswegen, wie lautet da die Anklage?
Nein, nein, das war halt so, also die haben die Teile gekauft und haben sie dann praktisch, also zum überhöhten Preis, an den ANV verkauft. Das war halt gesetzlich nicht irgendwie erlaubt, was weiß ich. Ich kenne mich mit DDR-Gesetz nicht so gut aus. Aber auf jeden Fall ist er deswegen ins Gefängnis gegangen.
Nehme ich die Wirtschaftsaktivität.
Offensichtlich. Ja, ja, es war dann teilweise so, dass die ganzen Betriebe irgendwelche Kit-Cam, irgendwelche Sachen vorweisen mussten. Und da mussten halt irgendwelche Computer her. Und irgendwie gab es keine. Und deswegen haben die sich dann am ANV welche besorgt. Und ja, die Betriebe hatten viel Geld. Und haben dann mal 20 Preise gezahlt. Und das war aber alles irgendwie...
Was war denn der offizielle Verkaufspreis eines Trabant damals?
Ein Trabant? Ich weiß jetzt nicht. Ein Trabant, wie du denen gehandelt hast. Von 10.000 bis 25.000. Ich selber war damals 17. Und ich hab mich nicht so für Trabants interessiert. Habe ich meine Nase schön am Schaufensterblatt gedrückt. Und ich selber habe aber dann einen bekommen von meinen Eltern, weil die glücklicherweise die UWS-Case verflügt haben. War lustig. Freu ich euch, muss man sagen. Aber was ich euch überhaupt sagen wollte, war das, dass ich Fritz sehr gut finde. Ich bin zur Zeit in Havelberg, auf dem Pferdemarkt. Und ich höre einen Sender seit drei Tagen und alles sehr optimaler Sound.
Herzlichen Dank, Thomas.
Alles klar. Und vielleicht können wir die Reichweite bis nach Ostthüringen erweitern, wenn ihr das dürft.
Das dürfen wir nicht, aber du kannst uns im Internet... Du kannst uns ja im Internet hören. Ja, www.fritz.de.
Nur heute nicht.
Doch, heute geht das auch, so haben wir einen Reel-Stream. Nur weil euer MPDi-Stream am Arsch ist, weil es ja kräftig ist. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass unser Reel-Stream nicht läuft. Thomas, danke für deinen Anruf.
Wir machen das gleich mal.
Was?
In Thüringen, wir schalten das an.
Genau, wir schalten einfach mal Thüringen an. Wir senden da Daten hin nach Thüringen. Jetzt kommt's, Kinnas. Also pass auf.
Roger?
Ich finde das klasse. Normalerweise rufen hier Leute an die Fragen, die haben das Problem, dass ihr Windows nicht geht. Roger hat eine Frage nach dem C64-Befehl. Ist das cool? Schieß mal los.
Jo, also ich hab den neulich rausgekramt und kann mich entsinnen, da gab's mal ein Befehl, mit dem konnte ich dieses Turbo-AWC und Run und Load mir sparen. Indem ich den Befehl eingeben hab, hab dann Press, Play und Tape gemacht. Und danach, der hatte Spielladen, gestartet, fertig. Und diesen Befehl suche ich wie bekloppt und keiner weiß den.
Befehl, um automatisch zu laden?
Ja, und dann das Spiel zu starten.
Sodass er automatisch Load und dann gleich Run macht? Das war Shift-Run-Stop.
Shift-Run-Stop?
Bei Basic Programmen hat das funktioniert, aber bei 0.8.1 nicht, oder?
Er redet von Tape, das ist kein 0.8.
Du meinst, du redest von einer abgekürzten Tastaturfolge?
Oder?
Oder nach einem bestimmten Kommando?
Das war eigentlich ein Kommando so.
Kenn ich auch nicht.
Schade, dass wir dir nicht helfen konnten, Roger.
Weißt du, was ein Rasterzahleninterrupt ist?
Nee, weiß ich leider auch nicht.
Weißt du, was ein Trabant gekostet hat? Das hat 89.
Dann sind wir jetzt quitt, Roger. So, wir haben einen, der weiß das. Alex? Was hat der C64 kurz vor der Wende gekostet?
Naja, für mich war es auf jeden Fall extrem teuer. Ich hab den schweren Fehler begangen, die Wende nicht vorauszusehen und hab einfach mal 10.000 Mark in die Licht.
10.000 Ost?
10.000 Ost für einen C64.
Wann wurde das gespielt?
Für einen grünen Monochrommonitor und eine Floppy. Ein Haufen diverse Spiele. Ja, und dann kurz zur Zeit später, ein paar Monate später, gab's dann also die Wende. Und dementsprechend neue Preise.
Ja, und noch ein Jahr später die 10.000 Mark 1 zu 1. Ich hätte dir echt den Arsch gebissen. Entschuldige.
Kein Problem, ich hab jetzt alles sehr viel Humor getragen. War nicht so weit da, traumatisch.
War das denn der offizielle Ladenpreis? Oder hast du den nur auf Umwege gekriegt? Also gab's Läden, wo man den kaufen konnte?
Das lief alles so unter der Hand. Im Grunde war es jemand, der ausreisen wollte und die ganzen Sachen abstoßen wollte. Und der hat natürlich ein fettes Schnäppchen gemacht. Naja, auf jeden Fall fällt mir noch eine andere nette Geschichte zum C64 ein. Als Rasterzeiteninterrupt fällt mir irgendwie muss noch ein diese ganze Demo-Geschichte vor den Spielen. Die Demos von den entsprechenden Cracker-Gruppen.
Die haben den verwendet?
Genau, die haben den verwendet für diese netten Bildabläufe. Wenn dann auch nicht die Balken hoch und Röse ist, dann sind die Krollen, alles möglich, Struppe frei etc. Jedenfalls konnte man ja so nette Sachen machen, zum Beispiel den Cursor auf die Bildschirmhintergrundfarbe einfärben, dann zum Beispiel Lod schreiben und irgendeinen Spiel laden, sodass die Sachen zum Beispiel im Prinzip blind abliefen. Und ich war damals bei den Tomaten, also noch zu DDR-Zeiten, der hatte halt den Sohn, so ein C64, und die Mutter wollte mir nicht glauben, dass es Programme gibt, die irgendwo bösartig sind. Also was heute klassisch über Viren und so weiter. Also im Prinzip war es einfach so, da gab es halt auch noch Sachen, dass irgendwelche Figuren auf dem Bildschirm rumrobsen und ewig nicht weggehen wollten, wenn man so was gestartet hat. Die wurden halt an Spiele meinten, ran rangehangen. Und dann haben wir das so gemacht, hab mich mit dem Typ dann abgesprochen und hab diesen Kurs halt eingefärbt. Wir haben das also im Prinzip Vorspiele gesetzt, was normalerweise liet, haben wir einfach die Namen ausgetauscht. Die das ganze Ding, dann tanzst du ein bisschen was über den Bildschirm und hieß dann ja, dein Programm wird jetzt gelöscht, konnte man ja alles machen. Und sie hat dann auf der Diskette halt nachgeschaut und hat halt im Prinzip dieses Spiel nicht gefunden. Das war halt ihr Lieblingsspiel, weil sie hat das mit dem C64 ungespielt. Na ja, sie haben natürlich viel gelacht, wie man sich vorstellen kann. Und das waren sie, die kleinen Programmiererfolge auf dem C64. Also es war wirklich sehr einfach.
Alex, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Tschüss. So Thürmond, um deine Frage von eben nochmal beantwortet zu kriegen. Hallo Daniel. Daniel, was hat der Trabi gekostet im Osten?
14.900 Ost. 14.900 Ost. Das heißt ein C64 wird für 16.000 verklappt und ein Trabant kostet 14.900.
Das war Listenpreis, Daniel.
Das war Listenpreis, genau.
Ich glaube, wenn man ihn gekauft hat, muss man auch ein bisschen mehr hinlegen.
Im Schwarzmarkt hat er 22.000 Ost gekostet.
Alles klar.
Das war mein Beitrag.
Vielen Dank für deinen Beitrag, Daniel. So, dann hat Sven ein C64 im Schrank. Möchtest du den gerne tauschen gegen einen TI-99A?
Lachen Nee, aber ich wollte euch nur sagen, die Szene in der DDR damals war C64, und KC85 und Z80A Prozessoren, die im Osten U880 hießen. Das war, denke ich, stärker verbreitet als im Westen teilweise. Da hat man sich irgendwie so drangeklammert, in jedem zweiten Treffen oder so, in Berlin war das Haus der jungen Talente, da war jeden zweiten Mittwoch riesengroße Tagartreffen mit irgendwelchen Kumpels aus Ungarn, die an Software rangekommen sind. Da gab es die frei verkäupt, auch die Rechner irgendwie. Im Osten gab es die nur unter der Hand. Eine Floppy hat zwischen 8.000 und 9.000 Mark gekostet. Wenn du die dementsprechenden Ketten haben wolltest, wurden da so um die 20-30 Mark immer Spräche gewesen. Also, die gab da also eine riesen Szene. Kaum ist die Software im Westen rausgekommen. Die gab es schon im Osten. Dann wurden doch irgendwie geknackt. Dann gab es 1.000 billigste Kopien. Man konnte kaum was lesen. Dann hat man das abgetippt. Die Checksumme war zum Schluss immer alles falsch gewesen. Aber das war ziemlich stark verbreitet gewesen. Und der hat zum Schluss im Intershop, wo er im Osten verkauft wurde, 600 Mark gekostet. West.
West.
Da konnte man die natürlich relativ schnell... Also, wenn Leute die Dinger verklingelt haben, die standen normal, also zweite Hand gab es im Osten nicht, aber ich sag mal in vergleichbaren Blättern oder so, sondern in Tageszeitungen, da wurden die ganz normal inseriert und so weiter. Und waren irgendwie Verhandlungsbasis zwischen 8.000 und 10.000 Mark, also das war schon ziemlich realistisch. Das hat dann so eine Sache getrieben, da gab es halt keine Joysticks oder so, da hat man sich doch was selber gebaut aus irgendwelchen erstschlag-sicheren Stahlmaterial irgendwo. Die Dinger waren wirklich unverwüstlich.
Hast du gerade erstschlag-sicheres Stahlmaterial gesagt? Darf ich das Wort in meinen aktiven Wortschatz aufnehmen?
Nee, wir haben da damals im Pionierhaus da so was nachgebaut, da hieß es, okay, Joysticks, wo soll man so eine Dinger herkriegen? Und dann wurde da einfach gebaut mit Stahlfedern und so einem Bagger da oben, eine Kuppel, eine Kugel drauf, die eigentlich da von irgendwelchem Schalthebel war. Mit Kuppern, die da drin irgendwie riesig waren. Aber das Ding konntest du dreimal tippen lassen, das hat immer noch funktioniert. Also, das war damals gerade wie bei so Zehnkampf und Fatal, das war da dieses ganze Joystick-Killer-Schuss.
Hyper-Olympics, ne?
Genau, genau, genau, das hat ewig gehalten. Aber die Szene hat einfach mal definitiv existiert.
Ja, und offensichtlich nicht schlecht.
Du hast ja auch einen Computer gehabt.
Ja, ja, also erst war das mal so ein ZX81. Kennt ihr den noch? Der wär ja noch schlimmer, mit einem Kilobyte und irgendwie konntest du auf dem sechsten Kilobyte irgendwie hochrüsten Folientastatur und nur Befehle auf der Tastatur siebenfach belegt und alles und so. Und dann irgendwann mal ein ZDM, ein C64.
Heute würde man das ein Notebook-Computer nennen.
Ne, aber so ein C64, ich meine sich davon trennen, so weit muss man einfach aufheben. Irgendwo nur stehen lassen, in dem Platz weg und irgendwann drin schmeißen, mal netten Abend mit ein paar Kumpels machen und alles.
Was hast du damit gemacht? Nur gespielt?
Na ja, ich sag mal, eine Mangelung eines Druckers, weil die denn ja waren in den ZU-Ostzeiten, also so richtig Mangelware, konntest du eigentlich gar nicht großartig was machen. Also ich sag mal, so eine DFÜ, die von wegen 300 baut und mit so einem Datafon oder wie die damals hieß, das ging ja nun gleich mal gar nicht in der SPZ, also konntest du ja nur spielen, teilweise dann mit Geos, irgendwelche Malprogramme, aber du konntest die Sachen halt nicht irgendwie ausgeben. Aber so Programmiersachen sind halt reichlich gelofen, gerade die ganzen Cracker-Vorspanne und so was alles. Also da ist reichlich, auch wie gesagt, die C64 intern und die 64, sowas kam immer irgendwie in Kopien oder sowas, wurde immer irgendwie verbreitet. Und Reismann hat sich hingesetzt und dann irgendwie die Listings abgeschrieben oder so. Also da waren ganz schlimme Sachen dabei. So wie heute im Copyshop reinigen und jeder hat es gehabt. War ja nicht, aber trotzdem, wenn du irgendwas wolltest, man kam irgendwie da ran.
Weißt du, was ein Rasterzeileninterrupt ist?
Nee, das war, wenn der Strahl von dem Bildschirm von der Röhre immer unten wieder angekommen ist, und dann hat er den Bildschirm praktisch zwei geteilt, wie jede zweite Zeile irgendwie so war das.
Ja, du bist nah dran, genau wie alle anderen.
Ja, aber so tiefmenschend ist irgendwie keine Ahnung hier.
Okay, kein Problem. Es gibt andere Dinge, die man wirklich wissen muss. Das gehört auf jeden Fall nicht dazu.
Sven, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Alles klar, tschüss.
Tschüss.
Dann 101, 5. Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter. In der Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 12 bis 8 Grad ab. Morgen wird es dann heiter und trocken bei Temperaturen um 23 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
In der mazedonischen Hauptstadt Skopje sind die ersten Bundeswehrsoldaten eingetroffen. Auch die Unionspolitiker Merz und Gloss sind nach Skopje gereist. Sie wollen sich ein Bild von der Truppenausrüstung und der Lage in dem Krisengebiet machen. Bei Angriffen der israelischen Armee ist am Abend ein Mitglied der Leibgarde von Palästinenser Präsident Arafat getötet worden. Auch in der von Israel besetzten palästinensischen Ortschaft Beit Jolla kam es zu einer Schießerei. Damit ist der für die Nacht angekündigte Abzug der israelischen Truppen wieder in Frage gestellt. Die Geschäftsfähigkeit der Bankgesellschaft Berlin ist wieder gesichert. Die Hauptversammlung beschloss am Abend die Erhöhung des Grundkapitals um 2, 2 Milliarden Euro. Eine entsprechende Zusicherung hatte der Berliner Senat gegeben, um die Bank vor der Schließung zu bewahren.
Vielen Dank, Gerald.
Bitte schön.
Fritz präsentiert...
Kim, live in Berlin.
Mittwoch, 19.
September.
Verlegt ins Velodrom.
Präsentiert von...
Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz mit Musik aus dem 64, weil die Sendung nämlich über den 64 geht. Und jetzt haben wir jemanden am Telefon, der heißt Korner. Hallo Korner. Zu welchem Spiel gehört dieses Lied?
Kenne ich nicht.
Ja, verloren. Ja, weswegen hast du einen angerufen, wenn du uns nicht sagen kannst?
Ich habe angerufen, weil ich den Rasterzahlen und darum erklären kann.
Ah, den hatten wir ja auch noch.
Also der BISC, der hat 48 Register und ich glaube in den erstenen, na ist egal, in irgendwelchen Registern auf jeden Fall, da kann man eintragen eine Rasterzahl und zwar eine bestimmte der X-Koordinate. Und wenn dieser Rasterstrahl diese X-Koordinat erreicht hat, wurde ein Interapt ausgelöst und dieser führte nun mit Hilfe eines Vektors auf seine eigene Routine und diese Routine führte halt alles aus, was man wollte. ZB mehr als 16 Farben, weil dann die Farbe gewechselt wurde und der BISC im Glauben war immer noch die alte Farbe zu benutzen und so eine Spielereinheit.
Genau, das ist ein Rasterzahl Interapt.
Man konnte sich da prima einklinken.
Also du hast programmiert auf dem C64.
Ja, ich hab auch Assembler programmiert. Ich hab z.B. versucht Super Mario Bros. umzusetzen, aber alleine hatte das halt nicht mehr hingehauen.
Und was hast du sonst noch so programmiert?
Basic, aber das war halt Papa la Papa.
Nee, ich meine mit Assembler.
Mehr hab ich da nicht so probiert und ein bisschen Spieleprogrammierung.
Und du hast auch einen 64 intern gehabt, denk ich mal.
Vielen Dank, Conor. Ingo? Ingo hat aufgelegt. Ich wollte von Ingo fragen, ob er das mit dem Interrupt bestätigen kann.
Das ist eine super akkurate Beschreibung von Rasterzahleninterrupt.
Wir haben ja mitgelesen.
Y ist und nicht X.
Ja gut, aber das kann ja mal passieren. Ich hab nicht die leiste Zeit, wovon ihr redet, Jungs. Alex, kannst du uns sagen, von welchem Spiel dieses Lied eben war?
Oh, das kann ich absolut nicht.
Vielleicht das hier, willst du mal hören?
Die Musik ist mir relativ bekannt. Allerdings nicht, dass sie nicht von welchen Spiel es ist. Ihr könnt ihr in den Tippen vielleicht Katakis?
Nee, hier steht, ich kenn's bloß auch nicht, The Last Ninja Wilderness In-Game.
Ah, der ganze Ninja Spiel, genau. So ein bisschen wie die Ablo heute, irgendwie so eine dreidimensional animierte Fläche. Ja, da musste man irgendwie die schön viele Räume senden und irgendwie die Leute ausknipsen. Also im Prinzip altes Programm. Zum Thema Spieler wollte ich auf jeden Fall nochmal was sagen. Und zwar gab's da eigentlich einen Programmierer, der eigentlich so wie alle Leuten bekannt war, Manfred Trenz, wenn mir der Name richtig in Erinnerung geblieben ist. Von dem stammt zum Beispiel Katakis oder auch Gratia Anasistas. Eingangs habt ihr auch in der Sendung irgendwie über dieses Spreit geredet, dass da irgendwie acht Spreits möglich waren. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass damals in der 64 irgendwie drinne stand, was er jetzt halt geschafft hat, über irgendwelche kleinen Tricks, halt im Prinzip auf dem Bildschirm mehr als acht Spreits gleichzeitig zu haben.
Genau, über den Interrupt. Der hat immer die ersten acht dargestellt und dann die nächsten acht. Und zwar so schnell, dass es fast ausgesehen hat, als ob es sechzehn wären.
Genau, da gab es ja mal dieses Supermonster zum Beispiel, am Ende von Katakis gab es doch immer. Irgend ein Supermonster war der alleine.
Die halbe Welt hat sich gefragt, wie hat er das so groß hingekriegt in der Auflösung? Und das waren dann halt diese doppelte Anzahl von Spreits. Aber das Flackern hat ihn halt verraten. Mit 0, 98 Megahertz ist es nicht so richtig, mit schnellen Animationen.
Das war auf jeden Fall damals wie heute Böhmische Dörfer für mich. Also in diesem Bereich bin ich nie vorgedrungen. Egal, da ist mir noch mal schön das Einifall zum Thema Musik. Leider ist nicht genau, wie das Ding heute heißt. Dieser Musikchip, dieser Sit, der wurde ja irgendwie ziemlich eilig entwickelt. Die Jungs haben damals ziemlich wenig Zeit gehabt, die ganze Sache sozusagen in die Produktion zu schicken. Und der war auch nicht wirklich sattig. Und der hat auch heftig viele Nebengeräusche. Und die haben das ganze Ding in irgendeiner schwedischen Uni irgendwo, haben diese Dinge jetzt vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, ein Jahr, zwei Jahre höchstens, noch mal neu aufgelegt als Synthesizer. Sodass man diese typischen C64 Sounds im Prinzip jetzt synthesizertechnisch nutzen konnte. Mit Tastatur irgendwie.
Ach, als Hardware?
Vorhin rief der Holger an, der da auch ein bisschen was über ZX81 erzählt hat und so weiter. Das ist Zufriedener bei so einem Freund von mir. Der wüsste ja genau, wie das Ding heute heißt. Echt?
Holger, ruf noch mal an und sag uns, wie das heißt, wir wollen uns das kaufen.
Und jetzt gibt es auch noch eine schöne Schicht zum Thema Computer in der DR. Vielleicht kennt ihr noch vom Erzählen, wenn er es nicht erlebt hat, PR, Produktive Arbeit, Einführung in die sozialistische Produktion. Da sollte natürlich für den Osten auch so ein bisschen die Nachwuchsprogrammierschaft herangezogen werden. Da haben sie irgendwann angefangen, zum Beispiel uns auch, im PR-Unterricht so zwei, drei Leute abzuzwacken, die ein bisschen Interesse an Computern hatten. Die sollten dann sozusagen auf diesen Karti 85 teilen, irgendwelche kleinen Sachen halt mal programmieren, sodass man jetzt irgendwie versucht, ein bisschen anzuschieben. Und dadurch, dass natürlich so im jugendlichen Bereich C64 und C6480 schon sehr verbreitet war, waren die meisten natürlich mit BESIC-Programmierung recht fit. Also die haben uns die Aufgabe gegeben, so jetzt programmiert hier mal irgendwie eine Zufallszahlenberechnung, so was wie Lotto, war natürlich in 5 Minuten erledigt. Und da war die Jugend auf jeden Fall deutlich schlauer als die Lehrer, die dann versucht haben, da irgendwas beizubringen.
Nicht DDR-typisch, meine ich, ausschließlich.
Das kommt generell so vor in Schulen mit Schülern, ich meine, das ist auch heute nicht so viel anders.
Ja, die Lehrer bleiben irgendwann stehen und haben irgendwie wahrscheinlich selber nicht mehr so richtig den Biss und bilden sich nicht weiter. War auf jeden Fall eine lustige Zeit. Also da habe ich auf jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß gehabt, weil ich dann nicht an einer Produktion an irgendeinem Fließband stehen musste, sondern konnte dann entspannt da irgendwelchen Kram auf dem Computer programmieren.
Hört sich noch eine Start-up-Firma an.
Naja, das Thema war da auf jeden Fall noch nicht an, ich glaube, das wäre auch zumindest in den Regionen ganz schön in die Hose gegangen, weil die Leute etwas Kopflos waren mit Computern. Und KC 85 fällt mir unheimlich schön an, war eigentlich immer im Osten, wie war der Begriff? Der KC 85, hast du eine Hand in der anderen Hand den Koffer für die Atombatterien. Ihr solltet immer einen Hammer dabei haben, weil die Tastatur, sagt jemand von euch, für unsere Stromlinienförmig, die reagierte auf jeden Fall nicht so richtig gut. Und da hat man uns schon immer gesagt, nimm lieber einen Hammer mit, hau rauf, dann klappen die Tasten.
Ach, das Ding war auch batteriebetrieben noch?
Na, batteriebetrieben nicht, aber aufgrund dieser typischen Osttechnik, wurde ja immer alle zwischen Kakao gezogen, ob es wirklich schlecht war oder nicht. Und da hieß es dann immer, nimm die Atombatterien und es gab eine Taste auf dem KC 85, die sozusagen einen Beep einstellte, dass man auch merkte, ob die Taste wirklich gezündet hat, wenn man drauf gedrückt hat. Ja, so war immer so eine hässliche Bek, Bek. So viel zu dem Thema.
Vielen Dank Alex.
Alles klar.
Da waren wir beim Sit-Chip und schwupp rufen noch mehr Leute an. Du bist nicht zu verstehen, leider rufst du vom Handy an.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Sam.
Wie hieß dieser Mensch, wie hieß er Sam?
Sit.
Nee, der gerade angerufen hat.
Wer jetzt?
Der eben klang, wie es wäre von einem Sit generiert worden.
Das hab ich schon wieder gelöscht. Was ist das?
Das war dieser Sprachsynthesizer auf dem 64er.
Ja, nee, das ist klar. Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was Sit-Station Schweden sein könnte? Nicht, gut, fragen wir mal nach. Hallo Sven.
Ja, hallo.
Was ist Sit-Station Schweden?
Ja, das hab ich mal auch vor einem Jahr, glaub ich, in der Keyboard gelesen. Diese Gruppe, die der Hörer vorhin gesagt hatte, die das entwickelt hat, das ist ein Musikinstrument, speziell mit diesem Sit-Chip zum Erstellen von Tönen, speziell für Techno jetzt, für die Musik. Und die haben irgendwie die restlichen Chips, die es in der Welt gibt, weil der von so einem Hergestellte aufgekauft und haben wohl 16.000 Geräte oder so.
www.sitstation.com Sicher? Ja, hab ich hier grad vor der Nase. Ja, das ist dann wahrscheinlich die Maschine, von der eben die Rede war.
Genau, genau.
65, 81 Soundchip.
Cool, das kauf ich mir, was kostet das?
Müsste bei 1000 Mark kosten, glaub ich, ungefähr.
Mit MIDI, geil, endlich ein C64-Sit mit MIDI.
Ja, das fällt mir dazu ein.
Das will ich haben. Vielen, vielen Dank, Sven. So, ich vermute Holger wollte uns dasselbe sagen.
Hallo, hallo, ich bin's nochmal.
Hat er recht, SitStation?
Ja, SitStation ist richtig. Das war so vor knapp zwei Jahren, gab's auch nur übers Internet zu bestellen, lag so bei reichlich 1000 Mark oder so. Es gab im Nachhinein aber zwei andere Geschichten in der Richtung und zwar einmal aus Ungarn oder so was, so ein Slot-Einschub für einen PC oder so was. Auch als eine Hardware-Basis, allerdings, sag ich mal, um das irgendwie anzustellen zu können, allerdings mit Steckplätzen für, ich glaube, vier Sit-Chips oder so. Das Problem war nur, die waren nicht mit bei, also man hätte sich irgendwo noch die Dinger besorgen müssen, also C64 ausschlachten und die Dinger da reinknöseln. Und inzwischen gibt's aber auch noch eine ganz andere Sache, irgendein Plug-In gibt, wo inzwischen was diesen Sit-Chip halt simuliert, das ist jetzt auch relativ neu, also ein oder zwei Monate, sag ich mal, ist das her, da stand es auch in einer Keyboard oder Keyboard irgendwie drin. Wofür? Na, ja, als Plug-In sag ich mal, was eben, ich weiß nicht, ob es Standalone war, oder ob es irgendwie, weiß nicht, unter VST oder sowas, also Cubase läuft, eben als Plug-In für ein PC und ich weiß nicht, für PC oder Mac oder beides, auf jeden Fall eben als Plug-In, was diese Geschichte simuliert. Es gibt ja nur diverse Software-Synthies inzwischen. Weiß nicht, eben auch bekannte Sachen, die halt irgendwie simuliert werden, weiß nicht, PPG oder Waldo oder wie auch immer. Und da gibt es eben jetzt auch irgendwie ein lustiges Plug-In, was eben vom Sound her, ich glaube, das war sogar einer ganz neuen jetzt irgendwie drin, also was wie gesagt diese Geschichte halt simuliert, den Klangcharakter von diesem Switchip, ne? Das war's dann auch schon.
Was hören wir da gerade, Tim? Ich glaube, ich möchte das noch mal von Anfang hören. Das klingt irgendwie sehr lustig. Alkanoid, oder?
Warte mal, das Programm heißt, wenn ich das richtig abgeschrieben habe, Turbotron. Turbotron.
Klingt irgendwie nicht schlecht für mich. Das Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz. Es geht um den C64, Musik kommt gerade vom C64.
Tim, was ist das?
Das ist die Musik von einem Spiel namens Bubble Bobble.
Ist das nicht? Das waren Zeiten.
Nee, nee doch nicht. Ich hab das jetzt gerade verwechselt. Nee, ich kenn's nicht. Lass mal nicht mehr über Spiele reden, reden wir doch mal über den C64.
Nachdem wir über den Soundchip jetzt etwas ausführlicher gesprochen hatten, gehen wir doch mal ein bisschen auf die Geschichte ein. Es gab ja nicht nur den einen C64, sondern es gab da durchaus im Laufe der Geschichte, im Laufe der Jahre unterschiedliche Modelle. Angefangen hat es mit dem C64 I, auch liebevoll Broadkasten genannt aufgrund seines Designs. Dann in 1986 hat man das Design leicht geändert, hat also so ein, ja ein pultförmiges Gehäuse für die Tastatur gefunden, ist von dem Braun auf einen Computer grau umgestiegen und hat dann eben den sogenannten C64 II oder auch C64 C genannt.
Das war aber nicht wirklich grau, das war eher so ein Cremefarben, also so Eierschal.
Ja, aber es war nicht mehr so braun wie der Broadkasten.
Ja, das stimmt, das sah aber auch ekelhaft. Also ich fand ja von der erste, der sah immer aus, als hätte er in einem Raum gestanden, in dem ein bisschen zu viel geraucht wurde.
Richtig, ja, na vielleicht war das auch schon in weiser Voraussicht auf die kommenden Nutzer, ich weiß es nicht. Ja, das war dann der C64-2, der dann letztendlich bis zum Ende produziert wurde. Es gibt dann noch einige weniger häufig verkauften Modelle. Eines davon war ein ganz besonderes Modell, und zwar der Goldene C64. Es wurden exakt 200 Stück davon produziert in Deutschland. Nachdem der ein millionste Commodore in Deutschland produziert wurde, hat man eine Sonderserie gemacht mit 200 C64, die also in einem goldenen Gehäuse gefertigt wurden. Die wurden dann nicht verkauft, sondern vergeben an bestimmte, dem C64 nahestehende Leute und so weiter. Nein, ich hatte keinen um Gottes Willen.
Der sieht ehrlich gesagt total schön aus. Ist das der Goldene?
Ja, mein Gott, das ist halt Gold. Das ist halt machen. Also zum Beispiel das C64 Magazin. Deutschland hat auch einen davon erhalten und so weiter. Dann gab es noch einen ganz zum Schluss, das war so ein portabler C64, ein C64 Schlepptop. Ja, den konnte man mit sich rumtragen und der hat ja auch so einen kleinen Monitor eingebaut, so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein 5 Zoll, 6 Zoll Monitor oder irgend sowas. Der wurde leider sehr wenig verkauft, obwohl er preislich eigentlich vernünftig war, aber es kam einfach zu spät und...
Total cooler Bildschirm.
Ja, und heute sind das unglaubliche Sammlerobjekte, diese Portablen C64. Jeder C64 Freak, der heute noch existiert, will eigentlich so ein Teil haben, aber es gibt halt einfach keine... Und die Stückzeilen waren so gering und man hat es dann auch wieder gelassen, den zu produzieren.
Mal bei Ebay gucken?
Selbst bei Ebay, was du... Das ist...
Guck mal. Klar, es gibt auch C64-Bösezeiten.
Ja, sicher, es gibt welche, aber ich meine, es sind ganz, ganz wenige und die weißen sind fantastisch.
Also der C64 Portabel, C64 Portabel, das spuckt nix aus.
Der heißt C64 SX. Ah ja, SX64, SX64, SX64, SX64, oder SX? Gut, so viel also zu dem C64. Es gab dann noch so ein paar andere Commodore-Reheimcomputer, die dem C64 verwandt sind. Es gab dann so einen Spin-Off, so einen billigen, könnte man fast sagen, das war der C16, der eben auch nur mit 16 Kilobyte Speicher war und alles etwas einfacher als der C64, aber preislich eben deutlich eine Region darunter für den Menschen mit dem kleineren Gelbbeutel. Später hat man dann versucht, die Serie fortzusetzen mit dem C128, der in unterschiedlichen Bauformen dann erschienen ist.
Was hast du gemacht mit den Fingern?
C128, ja, ja, ja. Also so einen richtig alten, der hatte so ein Desktop-Gehäuse und eine abgesetzte Tastatur. Und dann später kam der C128D irgendwie mit mit.
Fandest du den schicker, mit dem Brotkasten oder den C128?
C128 ist irgendwie sympathisch, ich weiß nicht. Der Brotkasten war so hoch und die Tastatur irgendwie so, ich weiß nicht, das war auch flacher.
So, gibt's ein Handbuch für ein SX64?
Ein Handbuch verkauft jemand und für viel verlangt er.
Drei Gebote ist jetzt bei 36 Mark, noch sieben Tage.
Naja, Handbuch. Das Handbuch alleine hilft dann nicht sehr viel.
Hast du bei ewe.de geguckt oder bei ewe.com?
Da werden auch Preise gezahlt, die jenseits von Gut und Böse sind für solche Sammlerstücke. Es gibt ja so bestimmte alte Computer, was ich auch, wenn man die Next Station und so denkt.
Zählt da zufällig auch ein TI-994A dazu?
Nee, glaub ich weniger.
Nicht, denn wir müssen weiter arbeiten. So, mal bei ewe.com gucken.
Ansonsten gab's natürlich auch innerhalb dieser ganzen C64-Sets, beim C64-2 gab's unterschiedliche Mainboard-Revisions und man hat kleinere Bugs korrigiert und Änderungen gemacht und so weiter. Da gibt's im Internet mittlerweile sehr ausführliche Dokumentationen dazu. Aber so tief wollen wir jetzt hier nicht absteigen.
Da müssen wir jetzt noch mal die Sicherheit haben.
SX64. Ein Gebot, 68 Dollar, noch 20 Stunden.
Tim, schlag zu.
68 Dollar scheint ein richtiges Sammlerstück zu sein.
Ein richtiges Sammlerstück.
Aber das hat Naten.
Nee, echt hier. Seht ihr, dass er funktioniert? Noch einer. Noch einer ist im Moment bei 26 Dollar. Das ist ein richtiges Sammlerstück.
Ich glaube, wir müssen mal den Sicherheitshinweis einblenden.
Sicherheitshinweis?
Ich soll mal den Sicherheitshinweis einblenden. Muss ich mal Rob Hubbard.
Ron Hubbard.
Rob Hubbard, kurz das Maul verbieten. Genau, das war Rob Hubbard.
Was gibt es jetzt?
Jetzt gibt es einen Sicherheitshinweis.
Hacking is not allowed in the Netherlands.
Das war der Sicherheitshinweis.
Von wem kam der da?
You don't have to commit crime to have a nice time.
Crimesch. Crimesch. Und Hacking is not allowed in the Netherlands.
No, it's not allowed in the Netherlands.
Ja, ihr wart auf der Halle. Können wir jetzt wieder Musik anmachen? Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz ist übrigens hier. Ja, aber das wollt ihr ja nochmal hören. Das Chaosradio 64, Blue Moon. Und weil es das Chaosradio Nummer 64 ist, reden wir über den C64 den ganzen Abend. Was fang ich an über den C64 zu reden?
Wir können den C64 gehäusemäßig verlassen und uns den Erweiterungen zuwenden, weil das war nicht zuletzt ein...
Du meinst, wie man hinten reingesteckt hat, womit man dann Spiele anhalten konnte und so was?
Ja genau, genau. Also es war nicht nur softwaremäßig irgendwie interessanter, leicht irgendwie was zu programmieren und tolle Effekte auf den Bildschirm zu bringen, sondern auch die Hardware-Architektur war eben sehr einfach und man konnte da alle möglichen Erweiterungen dazu basteln, in Bausatzform oder kaufen und so weiter. Und was es da gab, war ein Modul, auch Final Module und dergleichen, die hat man einfach in den Port gesteckt und konnte dann einfach in ein Spiel anhalten und war in einer Art Debugger und dann konnte man gucken, wo seine Highscores steht oder wie viel Schussmunition man jetzt noch übrig hat. Das konnte man einfach ein bisschen ändern und dann konnte man mit dem Spiel wieder weitermachen und solche Scherze. Ja genau, das war einfach alles sehr nett. Und Hardware-Basteleien, das geht bei ganz einfachen Sachen wie Relay-Karten an, dass man jetzt sagt, ich steuere jetzt meine Lichtorgel oder sonst irgendetwas mit dem C64 oder überall.
Lichtorgeln waren damals ja auch sehr modern.
Ja, sicher, das war ganz nett.
Kennst du das, dass der MPC-801 ist? MPC-801?
Nö, also ich kenne einen MPC-860.
Ein Matrix-Drucker, der unidirektional war, so ein billig Teil von Commodore selber. Ein schwarzes hässliches Teil, der nur unidirektional gedruckt hat. Also immer von links nach rechts eine Zeile auf den Drucker gedruckt hat. Aber dann nicht in der Lage war, rückwärts die nächste Zeile zu drucken, sondern immer wieder asthmatisch an den Anschlagen zurückliegt. Wie so alte Printer Terminals. Und es dauerte so unglaublich lange, bis dieser Kopf wieder am Anfang zurück war. Er hat einfach die Hälfte der Zeit darauf verschwendet, irgendwie sinnlos durch die Gegend zu fahren. Um diesen Drucker dann zu beschleunigen, konnte man auch eine Hardware-Modifikation vornehmen, und zwar indem man einen Gummiband nahm, und das Gummiband links befestigt hat und auch an den Kopf. So ein Schmuck hatte er trotzdem genug Saft, irgendwie um seine Zeile ordentlich zu drücken.
So, iiiih...
Und dann macht er halt so einen Sprung wieder vorne.
Und er druckte dann irgendwie locker 30% schneller.
Ja, das ist der Druckverschleuniger.
Das ist Tuning.
Wenn wir gerade schon bei Druckern sind, da gab es auch eine unglaublich coole Hardware-Bastelei. Und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo ich das her hatte oder wie ich dazu kam. Aber auf jeden Fall gab es die Möglichkeit, dass man mit einer LED und einer Fotodiode, die man auf dem Druckkopf Matrix-Druckers montiert hat und noch einige Hardware da rumherum, konnte man einen Scanner bauen mit dem C64. Und man hat den Drucker nicht als Drucker, sondern als Scanner verwendet. Und man hat nur den Papiertransport und den Wagen-Hin- und Rücklauf verwendet und die ganze Mechanik. Und eben durch diese LED und die Fotodiode, die man oben angebracht hat, konnte man dann mit, ich weiß gar nicht, welcher schlechten und unmöglichen Auflösung, aber man konnte scannen mit dem C64.
Das sind so Ideen, die haben sie im WDA Computer Club immer gehabt. Da hat dann dieser eine dicke Moderator von den beiden immer angefangen, irgendwelche Sachen aufzuschrauben und umzubauen. Das war immer sehr lustig.
Ja, in meinem Meinung man konnte das auch wirklich noch machen. Das ist einfach toll. Überhaupt die Kreativität, die die Leute damals irgendwie ans Licht gebracht haben mit dieser einfachen Hardware. Zum Beispiel dann die späteren Floppies, die die 15, was waren das, 1541.2, die hatten im Prinzip auch einen 65.02, den gleichen Prozessor. Und Leute, die dann so mathematisch aufwendige oder überhaupt rechentechnisch aufwendige Dinge wie Fraktale berechnen, Apfelmännchen, Hallebrot und so weiter, die haben dann einfach diese zweite CPU verwendet, um Parallel Processing zu machen und über die 9600 V Serie Schnittstelle irgendwas zu dem Floppy zu schicken und dann die CPU dort auch was berechnen zu lassen. Dann macht es auf einmal doppelt so schnell. Also es ist einfach cool, was die Leute damals für Ideen hatten und für kreativen Umgang mit dem Gerät.
Nein, den hat jemand anders interviewt. Die hat das Radio vor Ort auf dem Campinggelände...
Dann möchte ich das gerne ganz hören.
Okay, kommen wir zurück zu C64, unsere Hardware-Basteleien.
Ja, alles.
Was gab's da sonst noch? Interessante Hardware-Basteleien. Was mir jetzt noch so in den Kopf kommt, also die Tastatur, ich konnte mich mir da zum Beispiel nie sonderlich anverrösten. Ich war so träge und überhaupt. Also es gab dann zum Beispiel Schaltungen, mit denen man PC-Tastaturen, so ganz normale PC-XT-Tastaturen, an den C64 anschließen konnte. Es gab dann sogar Leute, die haben dann den C64 komplett in ein PC-Big-Tower-Gehäuse oder so eingebaut und da wird PC-Tastatur dann dran. Oh, ich schalte mal meinen PC ein, und dann kommt der C64.
So hat Windows also angefangen.
Und einen riesen Lüfter hinten dran.
Ja, was gab es sonst noch?
Und hochtacken doch auf den Gigahertz.
Ja, sagt das nicht mit dem Hochtacken. Es gab dann, wenn man so an die, das sind natürlich nur die extremen Liebhaber, wenn man an das Ende denkt, da gab es dann, extreme Liebhaberei ist Fetischismus, oder? Ja, so der C64-Fetisch, ja. Es gab wirklich dann so Super-CPUs, die bis 20 Megahertz gingen, wo man dann den kompletten C64 etwas umgebaut hat und mit schnelleren RAMs gestückt hat und schnellere CPU und so weiter und dann konnte man das mit 20 Megahertz bezahlen. Es macht wirklich auch praktisch eigentlich keinen Sinn, weil die Spiele laufen ja dann 20 mal schneller und wer kann dann da überhaupt mithalten oder so?
Wer übrigens noch überhaupt gar keine Vorstellung davon hat, was ein C64 ist oder wie es ist, irgendwie mit einem C64 umzugehen, weil er irgendwie immer nur einen PC gehabt hat oder einen Mac, der kann sich halt auch einfach prima mal schnell einen C64-Emulator laden. Da gibt es diverse, für diverse Plattformen, die auch divers gut funktionieren. Ähm, fallen wir jetzt gerade mal ein paar ein. Natürlich nicht, doch Frodo ist ein sehr verbreiteter Emulator, der irgendwie auf allen Plattformen irgendwie läuft. Und da gibt es auch noch ein paar spezielle für den PC und ein paar spezielle für den Mac, die für den Computer...
Ich meine, C64 plus Betriebssystemname, Suchbegriff.
Ja, also was sehr weit verbreitet ist das Weiß, VICE. Der kann also nicht nur einen C64, sondern auch C128 und den VC20 und überhaupt die ganze Commodore-Reihe emulieren. Und der ist im Source Code erhältlich, GPL lizenziert. Und man kann den unter Linux, unter Windows, unter Mac, ich weiß nicht, der kompletiert auf ziemlich allen Betriebssystemen mittlerweile.
Der versatile Commodore Emulator.
Ja, also der wird auch noch aktiv weiterentwickelt. Ich glaube, die haben erst Anfang August oder Ende Juli wieder eine neue Release gemacht, die 1.7. Also wer sich gerne mal damit beschäftigen will, der kann sich einfach so einen Emulator holen.
Und ne, 994.
Wenn man sich dann fragt, was mache ich mit dem Emulator, es gibt zum Beispiel auch Bausätze oder Bauanleitungen, wie man sich einen Kabel bastelt, dass man das alte C64 floppier an den PC anschließen kann, an die Serien-Schnittstelle. Oder es gibt natürlich auch Disc-Images, also von den ganzen Spielen und was es damals ebenso gab.
Es gibt sogar einen VC1541-Emulator, das ist die Floppy-Disc, die zum C64 dazugehört. Man kann nicht nur den C64 emulieren. Das war nämlich übrigens das Bemerkenswerte, dass diese Floppy ihrerseits auch ein vollständiger 65002-Computer war, genau wie der C64 auch. Da war ein 65002 oder ein 10 drin, ich bin beim C64, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Ich glaube, es war auch der 65010. Und halt einfach so Speicher und alles, also so ein richtiger Computer. Dieses Kabel, das die beiden Maschinen miteinander verbunden hat, war schon mehr so ein Netzwerkkabel, weil das ja irgendwie zwei vollständige Computer waren, die ja miteinander kommunizierten. Und eben nicht irgendwie nur so ein dummes Teil, was direkt mit Hardware draufgeschrieben wird.
Und wenn man eben wirklich zu seinem Emulator irgendwie Software brauchte, gibt es Websites, die damit werben, dass sie über 2000 C64-Spiele haben. Und die kann man auch einfach downloaden. Das ist zwar eigentlich legal irgendwo eine Grauzone, aber ich meine, die Spiele, das Copyright, das Copyright ist sicherlich nicht expired, aber die Spielefirmen, die diese Spiele damals produziert haben, entweder sie existieren nicht mehr oder sie haben einfach kein finanzielles Interesse daran, es zu verfolgen, wenn da heute noch jemand irgendwas kopiert. Und da gibt es einfach Sites, die das öffentlich anbieten. Das kann ich irgendwie geheim oder sonst was.
Es war damals sowieso relativ relaxed. Also selbst Commodore hat auch nie irgendwelche Schritte unternommen, wenn die Leute zum Beispiel das ROM ausgelesen haben und kopiert haben, damit du da irgendwelche Sachen nachbauen kannst.
Ja, ich meine, sie haben ja kräftig verdient, damit sie 17 Millionen Computer verkauft haben. Ich meine, was ist das?
Ja, die haben bestimmt irgendwie keine schlechte Zeit gehabt.
Das war dann aber auch das letzte Mal, dass Commodore was verdient hat, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, also die Amiga-Zeiten muss man schon auch noch.
Und mit dem eigentlich noch einen Ruf?
Im Moment nicht. Wir haben gar nichts gefragt. Die nächste Frage wäre wohl nach Hörern, die selber irgendwelche C64-Hardware-Basteleien irgendwelche ausgefallenen Dinge gebaut haben und in Bezug genommen haben.
Oder noch ein bisschen haben.
Oder noch ein bisschen haben, selbstverständlich. So Rollatensteuerung oder irgendwie sowas.
Hardware-Basteleien am C64, falls ihr da Erfahrung mit habt, dann meldet euch doch mal bei uns und erzählt uns.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Das ist der Beweis. Jean-Michel Jarre hat seine ganzen Platten auf einem SIT-Programm geliefert. Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz. Wir würden ganz gerne, weil wir heute über den 64 reden, mit euch darüber reden, was für Hardware-Bastilleien ihr denn vielleicht am C64 vorgenommen habt, noch vornehmt oder von denen ihr vorgenommen gehört zu haben vorgegeben habt.
0331 für Potsdam sind 70, 97, 110.
Ich hab mal gelernt, dass du über 50% aller Sätze, wo du den Faden verloren hast, mit dem Wort sind beenden kannst. Und es ist in der Regel richtig. Also mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle, muss man drauf achten, sind. Hardware-Bastilleien am C64, 0331, 70, 97, 110. Hallo Jens.
Oh, meine Ohren, aua.
Was denn?
Ist doch schön.
Doch ein bisschen Jean-Michel Jarre Jens, kein Problem.
Hast du nicht den Titel von Musik von Turricans 2 da?
Na, spiel mal vor. Wir sind ganz oa. Press Play on Tape.
Schwier.
Turricans 2, ich hab ein Remix davon.
Ja, aber nicht vom C64. Also von Amia oder so, das ist ja geil.
Aber Turrican war auch geil. Der Programmierer von dieser Musik, Chris Hülsbeck. Mit einer kleinen Sonnenbrille. Das wird's mag sein, aus dem letzten Jahr gibt's ein CD, Chris Hülsbeck in the Mix heißt die. Und da hat er sich noch mal hingesetzt und die Dinger ein bisschen aufgepeppt.
Ja, willst du die Original-CDs haben, die ohne Mix?
Ja, schick mal zu, klar.
Ja, hab ich. Ja, ich hab da mal Lichtgriffe gebaut, einfach mit so einem Fototransistor und so.
Lichtgriffe?
Ja, Lichtgriffe.
Light Pen heißt das natürlich auf Neudeutsch.
Was macht das?
Das hieß damals auch schon so.
So quasi eine Position feststellen. Wenn du mit dem Finger auf dem Bildschirm Tipps hast, hast du mit diesem Light Pen darauf getippt und der hat dann die Position da.
Und zwar in Hardware, deswegen hat das überhaupt nur geklappt.
Ja, und dann gab es eine tolle Basic Erweiterung, natürlich Simon's Basic, in der welche auch als Steckenmodul vorhanden war. Und dann gab es diese Variable, Pen X, Pen Y, die man auslesen könnte. In dieser Variable war die Position des Lichtgriffes drin, da konnte man mit malen. Was aber ziemlich bescheiden bei mir funktioniert hat. Ich konnte mehr Striche mitmachen. Wenn man die Lichtgriffe aus dem Bildschirm gezeigt hat, dann war quasi horizontal eine Linie da. Das war wahrscheinlich an meinem Transistor geschuldet, der nicht ganz optisch okay war.
Diese Lichtgriffe-Geschichte war hardwareunterstützt, der Graphik-Chip im C64 hatte die Möglichkeit, neben diesem tollen Rasterzweigeninterrupt auch Interrupts zu generieren, eben für Lichtgriffe-Funktionalität.
Toll, wie weitsichtig die damals schon waren. Und natürlich hab ich noch mal auf den Turiken zurückgekommen. Da musste man manchmal eine Space-Taste drücken, damit der Kerl auch was gemacht hat. Das war mir so nervig, diese blöde Space-Taste zu drücken. Da wollte ich dann auf der Platine einen Schalter anlöten. Leider hab ich nicht beachtet, dass mein Lötkorn nicht richtig geerdet ist. Danach waren irgendwelche Portbausteine kaputt. Aber bei Conrad bestellt und eingelötet, fertig. Aber vorher den Lötkorn geerdet und dann ging's irgendwie. So was kann auch passieren.
Die waren ziemlich empfindlich, diese Portbausteine. Ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass Leute dann gleich Sockel aufgelötet haben auf die Platine, damit man die schneller tauschen kann, wenn sie wieder geschossen sind. 30 irgendwas, glaube ich.
Holger?
Ja?
Was ist denn mit dem Amiga-Blumen?
Darüber reden wir jetzt nicht.
Ja, ich weiß, okay.
Einen schönen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Lichtgriffel fällt mir ein. Da gab's doch auch immer diese Pistolen, wo irgendwie vorne eine Leuchttiode drin war oder so. Wild Gunman oder wie du siehst, keine Ahnung. Wild Gunman war aus Back to the Future. Wie haben die eigentlich funktioniert?
Keine Ahnung.
Die Pistolen waren ganz einfach. Die hatten vorne einen Sensor drin. Die musste es ja direkt auf dem Bildschirm draufhalten.
Nee, ein Stück weit weg?
Nein, nein.
Nein?
Du musst sie ziemlich nah dranhalten. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie nah man sie dranhalten muss, aber relativ nah, weil der Punkt ist, dass in dem Moment, wo der Lichtstrahl, der den Bildschirm aufbaut, der CRT-Strahl, an dieser Gann vorbeikommt, strahlt er halt stärker rein und der Sensor merkt halt diese Intensität. Und diese Position wird in dem Moment dann irgendwie über einen User-Poser oder das Ding auch immer angeschlossen war, direkt in die Software geladen und die schaut halt, an welcher Stelle, kann im WIC direkt in diesem Chip direkt auslesen, an welcher Position sich der Strahl gerade gefunden hat.
Vielen Dank für diese Information. Du hast einen einfachen Moderator sehr glücklich gemacht. Hardware-Bastelein am C64, wollen wir von euch hören.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Name Drödel.
Ja, genau.
Du hast was gebaut?
Ich habe eine Relaiskarte gebaut, die man auch bei Konrad bestellen konnte.
Und dann halt zu Hause so zusammenlöten.
Und an dieser Relaiskarte konnte man dann einen Roboterarm mit ansteuern. Und dann halt eben hoch runter, rechts links, wie man sich das so vorstellt. Ich suche allerdings eigentlich auch noch ein Programm dafür, weil meine Disketten sind ja mittlerweile leider alle kaputt.
Also haben sich aufgelöst mit der Zeit.
Recht, die lösen sich auf?
Ja, na gut, ich meine nicht physikalisch. Die funktionieren einfach nicht mehr. Und ich würde das Ding gerne mal wieder in Betrieb nehmen. Wenigstens die Relekarte, den Roboterarm, der ist mittlerweile auch längst kaputt. Und ja, suche halt auf diesem Wege, hier auch wieder an Software dranzukommen, vielleicht übers Internet. Vielleicht meldet sich da ja mal jemand, der vielleicht auch noch dieses Teil kennt. Na ja, und vielleicht gibt es ja auch Erfahrungen, was eben andere noch damit gebaut haben, was ich vielleicht auch verwirklichen könnte. Ich wollte früher immer damit meine CDs in CD-Player tun, aber dafür war das Ding irgendwie nicht ausgelegt. Also die Feinmotorik, die war da nicht ganz so hundertprozentig.
Aber frag doch mal eine Suchmaschine deiner Wahl.
Ja, aber da ist ja nichts dran zu kommen. Wo ihr jetzt gerade dieses geniale Thema aufgreift.
Ich kann dir jetzt auch keinen Hinweis geben, aber ich denke an Informationen über C64 und über diese Bastel-Hardware gibt es eigentlich genug. Für deinen Roboterarm hätte ich vielleicht einen Tipp, eine Schrittmotorkarte wäre wohl wesentlich geschickter. Und Schrittmotoren im Roboterarm statt nur mit Release, da kannst du viel gezielter ansteuern. Ist auch nicht weiter kompliziert.
Ja, na gut, ich fange da jetzt mal wieder mit an. Ich habe mir auf die Idee gebracht, meinen C64 mal wieder raus.
Cool, cool, cool. C64 forever.
Keine Ursache und schönen Abend noch.
Und immerhin hast du irgendwie gezeigt, dass du dich durch den Chat nicht verwirren lässt. Jetzt hat er doch nicht Sint gesagt.
Sint hat einen Faden verloren gehabt. Er wollte Sint sagen. Julian? Was hast du gebaut?
Ich hab mal einen Dorfdisco, hab immer eine Lichtanlage gebaut mit einem C64. Und zwar relativ modern, also einmal konnte man irgendwelche Lichtfolgen durchschalten und dann war die ganze Sache aber noch an die Musikanlage gekommen, das heißt, es konnte sogar am Takt weiterschalten. Und zwar habe ich da ausgesucht, dass der Soundchip, der hatte damals irgendwelche Filter gehabt. Da konnte man irgendwelche Tiefpassfilter einstellen und dann habe ich darüber auch einen Interact ausgelöst. Dann könnte man sogar am Takt der Musik das weiterschalten. Das habe ich glaube ich sogar in der Sammler geschrieben. Und dann wollte ich noch erzählen, es gab noch den C plus 4.
Hast du einen gehabt?
Nein, ich hatte einen C16, aber er weist auf 64 Megabyte, sowas gab es auch. Angeber. Dann hatte er 64 Kilobyte gehabt. Und dann gab es noch so ein Mittelding zwischen C16 und C64, das war der C plus 4. Der hatte auch den Prozessor vom C16 glaube ich, aber 64 Kilobyte und noch irgendwelche fest eingebaute Software in den Raum glaube ich, Textverarbeitung und sowas.
Stimmt, da war was, ich erinnere mich an Düster.
Gar keine Ahnung.
Der war auch nicht sehr verbreitet, weil einfach die Spiele nicht gelaufen sind. Das ist sehr ähnlich wie heute mit Windows, dass er hauptsächlich zum Spielen benutzt wird.
Anstatt ein vernünftiges Besuch zu machen.
Genau, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, eine andere Sendung bestimmt. Es war zwar ein Office-Paket, Textverarbeitung, Tabellenkalkulation und eine Datenbank. Und ein DFÜ-Programm. Die Spiele liefen halt nicht. Obwohl es auch 64 Kilobyte war und alles ganz ähnlich, hat es halt nicht funktioniert. Das erste Mal, wo man dachte, ah, inkompatibel. Ab dem Moment hat sich dieses Wort so durchgesetzt und verfolgt uns heute noch.
Viral verbreitet irgendwie. DFÜ, ging das eigentlich mit dem C64?
Ja klar, in Amerika. Ich hatte damals einen 100er-Loch, das waren 64er. Und da hat man in einer Aktionswoche ein Modem dazu bekommen, umsonst, wenn man sich das da gekauft hat. Und es hatte dann 300 Baut, und da konnte man sich in den E-Box einloggen.
Ich frage, weil hier ruft gerade ein Benjamin an. Hallo Benjamin. Von was hast du gehört?
Von so einer Art Lichtmodem.
Allerdings, das hatte so irgendwie vier Baut oder so.
Schon mal gehört? Nein, nein. Ich kann mich dran erinnern. Ich habe das noch. Das ist ein Hobbitekbuch mit Jean Pütz, wo er leckere köstliche Nachspeisen biologisch abbaubar macht. Da ist eine Bauanleitung drin für ein Gerät. Es überträgt keine Daten. Es ist nicht binär, sondern auf irgendeine Form analog. Da kannst du mit Licht Sprache übertragen. Das ist tatsächlich zwei Kanonen. Die kannst du 400 Meter entfernt aufstellen. Kannst du hier drüber unterhalten. Das wird übers Licht übertragen.
Also das, wovon ich gehört hatte, die haben das dann dazu verwendet, um Schiffe versenken miteinander zu spielen.
War das nicht die Hardware, mit der man die da im Computer Club links oben, dieses blinkende Quadrat, damit konnte man das dekodieren. Das heißt, die haben da während der Sendung nebenbei Listings sozusagen gebroadcastet.
Und zwar, ich hatte das in einer C64 Zeitung gelesen, habe ich mir nämlich vor einiger Zeit einige aus Ebay ersteigert. Und die haben das so gemacht, also die hatten eine Taschenlampe und ein Lichtsensor und die hatten zwei gegenüberliegende Balkone und dann haben die dadurch die Daten ausgetauscht.
Ja, interessant, interessant. Aber was es noch vielleicht zur DFÜ und dem C64 zu sagen gibt, es gab tatsächlich einen, ich meine, in Deutschland war das ja nicht so einfach mit einem Modem, einfach dazu und so. Ich meine, da gab es ja die Post und die hat da drüber gewacht, dass auch niemand hier irgendwelche umfass zugelassenen Dinge betreibt, die ja völlig illegal gewesen wären.
Schlussansage ist so das Zauberwort da.
Was es aber gab, sehr wohl, war ein Modem für BTX. Damit konnte man den C64 dann als BTX-Terminal nutzen. Damit man mit diesem Modem auch gar nichts Böses anstellt, konnte man keine Nummer wählen, sondern es gab nur eine Tastin, und wenn man die gedrückt hat, dann wurde die BTX-Nummer gewählt, aber man konnte nicht irgendwie das anderes machen.
Die Franzosen verkaufen das als Minitel heute noch. Benjamin, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Aber das mit dem Lichtmodem finde ich eine interessante Sache. Du musst ja im Prinzip nur einen Morse Code übertragen. Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz und der C64 unser Thema und wir wollten von euch Hardware-Basteleien hören.
Ah ja, gut, wunderbar, bin aufwendung. Ich hab damals mit dem C64 ein System gebaut, mit dem ich so Chemiesynthesen überwachen konnte. Ich war damals ein bisschen als Hobbychemiker unterwegs und gab da so Zeug, das ziemlich lang gedauert hat und da hab ich gedacht immer daneben stehen und gucken was es gerade macht, ist irgendwie langweilig und da hab ich mein C64 dafür eingesetzt.
Aha, und wie hat das funktioniert, was hast du da genau gemacht?
Na ja, ich hab halt zum Beispiel die Temperatur überwacht von dem was ich da gerade gekocht habe und irgendwie Salzgehalt und so ne Sachen und dann hab ich da noch so ein Servo angeschlossen aus dem Modellbau und dann hab ich immer Hähnchen auf, Hähnchen zu und irgendwelche Flüssigkeiten dazu getropft und so. Und so wenn ich Glück hatte, hat's auch funktioniert.
Was hast du da für Sensoren genommen, waren das? Welche Sensoren hast du da genommen? Also die müssen ja ihre Werte dann auch irgendwie dem 64er mitgeteilt haben.
Ja, also temperaturempfindliche Widerstände und so ein Zeug für die Temperaturmessung. Und dann hab ich noch, also die Idee dazu hatte, ich hab bekommen, da war ein C64-Magazin, mal so eine Bauanleitung für so ein Messlabor für alles mögliche, irgendwie Redaktivität, Windstärke und so ein Zeug. Und das hab ich ein bisschen modifiziert, dass das hingehauen hat. Und so Salzgehalt war noch die Sache. Und das hab ich dann so über die Leitfähigkeit imitiert. Also wie viel Strom da halt durchfließt.
Und das ist alles mit Assembler programmiert?
Ja, war ziemlich böse aufwendig damals.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wann war das?
Das war Anfang der 90er ungefähr. So 1991, 1992 glaube ich.
Was sind da so deine Tools gewesen, die du zum programmieren verwendet hast? Weißt du das noch?
Gute Frage. Ich hatte da glaube ich auch aus dem 64er Heft irgendeinen Assembler abgetippt gehabt, mal so HYBRAS oder so. Ich glaube den Vorgänger hatte ich auch noch, TurboAS oder so, ja nicht hieß das Ding. Und mit dem hatte ich dann so einen Disassembler hatte ich auch noch, wenn irgendwie ein Programm mal Mist gebaut hat. Aber das war alles nicht wirklich performant damals. Geht heute stellenweise bequemer mit Hochsprachen.
Ja natürlich, ganz anderer Seiten.
Ich bin da auch übelst lange dran gesessen an diesem Ding.
Wenn du es länger gebraucht hättest, um daneben zu stehen und warten bis es fertig ist.
Klingt auch nach einer sehr interessanten Anwendung. Also hab ich auch noch nicht gehört so was.
Ein Drogenlabor, ein automatisches Drogenlabor, das C64 beträgt.
Wir warten noch jemand von Kernkraftwerk, der anruft.
Manu, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
Null Uhr, dreiunddreißig.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht zwölf bis acht Grad am Tage, also quasi morgen, heiter und trocken, wie wir alle bei Temperaturen zwischen 25 und 25 Grad. Eigentlich hätte ich sagen sollen bis 25 Grad, habe ich aber verkackt. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötterheim.
In der mazedonischen Hauptstadt Skopje sind die ersten Bundeswehrsoldaten eingetroffen. Auch die Unionspolitiker Merz und Gloß sind nach Skopje gereist. Sie wollen sich ein Bild von der Truppenausrüstung und der Lage in dem Krisengebiet machen. Bei Angriffen der israelischen Armee ist am Abend ein Mitglied der Leibgarde von Palästinenser Präsident Arafat getötet worden. Weitere 15 Palästinenser wurden verletzt, unter ihnen auch Kinder. Die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen steuern auf ein Rekorddefizit zu. Im ersten Halbjahr 2001 sei voraussichtlich ein Minus von rund 5 Milliarden Mark entstanden, teilte die kaufmännische Krankenkasse am Abend mit. Sie bestätigte damit Presseinformationen.
Danke, Gerald.
Am Freitag gibt es was zu feiern. Die erste lange IFA Nacht der Welt. Die internationale Funkausstellung in Berlin ist am Freitag bis Mitternacht geöffnet. Und an der großen Fritz-Bühne in Halle 1.1 stehen eure Lieblings-Fritz-Moderatoren hinter den Platten-Tellern. Zum Beispiel Holger Klein um 19 Uhr oder Treiber Wilson um 19.30 Uhr oder M. Zürich um 22 Uhr oder auch Steffen Halaschka um 23 Uhr. Die lange IFA-Nacht. Am Freitag von 18 Uhr bis Mitternacht auf dem Messegelände unterm Funktor und im Radio Fritz.
Warum kriegen wir eigentlich immer ein Lachflasch?
Diese rote Lampe, pappelige Reflexe.
Das ist doch irgendwie scheiße.
Ne, eigentlich nicht.
Guten Abend.
Wir Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz und wir schweifen jetzt einfach mal ab. Ist ja vor zwei Wochen war ja herr.
Schön, dass du fragst.
Das war ein Zufall, wir haben auch die ganze Zeit jetzt gerade Lichter.
Vielleicht kurz bevor wir das mit der Hälfte...
Mit vollem Mund spricht man nicht, ich hatte die Mutti, der doch...
Ich weiß, der ist nicht voll.
Hast du noch Schokolade?
Ist alles schon weg?
Toll.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Termin, auf den ich kurz zu sprechen kommen wollte. 12.09.2001.
Das ist ja noch.
Das ist jetzt noch irgendwie zwei Wochen.
Das ist heute in zwei Wochen.
Also in genau zwei Wochen?
Hab ich vorher Geburtstag, schenkst du mir was?
Hast du vorher Geburtstag und dann ist irgendwann der 12.09. und der Geburtstag ist vorbei.
Ja, lang.
Was gibt es denn anderen?
Wie alt wirst du denn Holger?
Das sag ich nicht.
Ach komm Holger, komm.
Ich wäre nicht viel älter, also nicht viel jünger als Frank Steffel.
Hast du dich jetzt auch in Microsoft-Produktnamen als Vorsilbe fordern eigentlich machen sollen?
beitragen?
Wie Axel Klein eben schon korrekt bemerkte, stehen einige Geburten vor. Bitte dich, willst du mich beleidigen? Power-Prittler.
Ja.
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich am 12.9.?
Das weiß ich doch nicht.
ist Geburtstag.
Ach, von wem?
Vom Chaos Computer Club. Ja, wirst du mal.
Das wird auch gefeiert.
Wie viele Tage vorher hab ich das?
Das kriegen wir jedes Jahr hin. Der 20.
Ach, das ist ja quasi Jubiläumsartig.
Das ist total Jubiläumsartig.
Das ist halt im Dezimal-System so eine freie Interpretation einer besonderen Zahl. Auch wenn wir das nicht unbedingt zwingend nachempfinden können, weil da andere Zahlen irgendwie sehr viel magischer sind, wie zum Beispiel die dieser Sendung, haben wir uns gedacht, dass wir das nicht unbedingt zwingend nachempfinden können, weil da andere Zahlen irgendwie sehr viel magischer sind, wie zum Beispiel die dieser Sendung, haben wir uns gedacht, beginnen wir aber das Ganze mal ein bisschen und machen auch eine kleine Ausstellung dazu, die irgendwie vom 12.9. bis zum 16.9. laufen soll, in der Kongresshalle am Alexanderplatz in Berlin.
Ach, jetzt drehen wir richtig auf.
Ja, das ist irgendwie ein schönes Gebäude. Ja, das ist ein schönes Gebäude. Und wir sind gerade ganz eifrig, irgendwie Dinge zusammenzutragen, die das alles mal ein wenig beleuchten, was irgendwie so in diesen 20 Jahren abgegangen ist, weil es halt nicht nur 20 Jahre Chaos Computer Club sind, sondern es sind irgendwie 20 Jahre auch Personalcomputer. Der ist ja auch gerade vor einem Jahr irgendwie geäußert. Jetzt machen wir natürlich keine Computerausstellung, sondern irgendwie erzählen schon ein bisschen auch was von uns. Aber natürlich auch mit Computern. Und es gibt Exponate. Es soll diverse Exponate zu bewundern geben und irgendwie gemütliche Atmosphäre versuchen wir dort zu schaffen. Und wer irgendwie in Berlin ist und irgendwie Lust hat, sich das anzuschauen, hat halt da mit freiem Eintritt die Möglichkeit genau dieses zu tun.
Auch noch freier Eintritt?
Wir stellen da alles hin und machen das irgendwie halbwegs benutzbar. Schick. Wir bemühen uns und würden freuen, wenn wir euch dort sehen könnten.
12.9. das ist heute in 14 Tagen in der Kongresshalle am Alexanderplatz. Ab wie viel Uhr bist du das schon?
Ab 12 Uhr tagsüber?
Ja, so von 12 bis 12. Es geht bis Sonntag ein, schließlich. Also es geht irgendwie bis 12, aber das weiß ich, wie lange das dann irgendwie geht, weil wir haben ja dann irgendwie auch unser Internet da und dann, weißt du, vergeht die Zeit ja immer so schön.
Wir waren doch bei der Hall. Und ich hatte von einer dreiviertel Stunde gesagt, dass ich dieses Interview gerne hören würde. Du erinnerst dich?
Ja, das tolle Interview. Das haben wir ja eben schon, dieses Lied, das wir dir die ganze Zeit gehört haben. Du erinnerst dich? Erinnerst du dich?
Hacking is illegal in the Netherlands.
Ja, du weißt schon irgendwie. Und das ist jetzt nicht nur irgendwie ein lustiges Lied, sondern hier, ich kann das ja noch mal kurz irgendwie zum Besten geben.
Hacking is not allowed in the Netherlands.
Das ist irgendwie aus einem Interview mit einem Polizisten, der auf der Hell irgendwie in seinem hübschen Auto herumsass und irgendwie uns alle bewacht hat und aufgepasst hat, dass wir keine bösen, bösen Dinge tun.
Ach, da sagst du, Hänchenfeld stand ein Auto da und da saß ein einsamer Polizist in der Donuts gegessen oder wie?
Nein, dieses ganze Hackerlager war halt im Prinzip datenmäßig vollständig umzingelt. Die saßen also mit der großen Datenschere da irgendwie in ihrem Wagen und haben geradezu darauf gewartet, dass jetzt irgendwie gleich irgendwie der dritte Weltkrieg programmiert wird und dann hätten sie halt in diesem Fall die doch recht potente Internetanbindung, die diese Veranstaltung gehabt hat, einfach mal abgeschnitten. Und das haben sie auch klar vorher kommuniziert. Das ist halt jetzt auch durch jüngste Gesetzgebungen in Holland alles irgendwie wunderbar abgedeckt. Irgendwie, wenn er irgendwie böse sind, dann machen wir da einfach mal ab. So, dazu ist es nicht gekommen, weil halt auch nichts nichts Böses bekannt geworden ist. Also keine Ahnung, was irgendwie da passiert ist. Es gab irgendwie so ein megamäßiges Internet, was nicht wirklich abhörbar gewesen ist. Also es gab irgendwie Sustain 200 Megabyte pro Sekunde Datentransfer. Entschuldigung, 200 Megabit.
Das wäre eine mittlere Kleinstadt, ne? Wie viele Leute waren da?
3000.
Das wäre eine mittlere Kleinstadt.
Die Leitung wurde nicht ausgenutzt, weil es war ein Gigabit da. Man war ja direkt auf dem Universitätsgelände und konnte dann irgendwie da so, naja, also das war alles schon sehr performant. Wenn man da mal auf irgendetwas geklickt hat, dann kam das einem ziemlich nahe vor. Dieser Polizist wiederum, der wurde halt interviewt von irgendwie dem ortsansässigen Radio, Spacestation 5, die halt dort irgendwie ein nettes Radiozelt aufgebaut haben.
Also Campradio nur, ne?
Genau, die also auf dem Gelände mit UKW rausgestrahlt haben, aber natürlich auch auf dem Netz und sich dann irgendwie zahlreiche Leute irgendwie gegriffen haben und die halt interviewt haben. Wer auch immer, da lief irgend so ein Verrückter herum, verkleidet wie Lara Croft, der musste vor das Mikrofon und dann gab es irgendwie natürlich auch Anrufehörer, wie wir das hier auch haben, aber die riefen dann irgendwie auch gleich aus Chicago an und irgendwann wurde dann eben auch dieser Polizist sozusagen aus seinem Wagen gezerrt und sollte man sich so ein bisschen äußern. Das ist natürlich ein interessanter Einblick irgendwie in die Denkweise von solchen Leuten. Dann können wir ja einfach mal kurz das Interview anhören.
Ich bitte darum noch. Sie sind von dem Regierung, den offiziellen Polizeistations.
Ich bin von der Cybercrime Unit, aus der östlichen Seite des Landes. Wir waren auch bei HIP 97, weil das auch in einem Ort war, das in unserem Land gehört. Wir haben versucht, die Publikationen auf der Internet und in der Presse zu folgen. Und wir haben das gefolgt und deswegen sind wir jetzt hier.
Das ist ein wirklich schwieriges Thema für dich, ich denke, das ist Hacker-Kontent hier.
Wie reagieren die Menschen auf die Polizei?
Also, es muss anfangen. Ich glaube, dass es nicht wirklich ein Problem ist, dass wir hier sind. Ich erwarte von allen Teilnehmern, die hier sind, dass sie alle ehrt, neue Dinge in neuen Technologien zu finden. Sie wollen ihre Wissen über neue Technologien teilen.
Vielen Dank für diese Interview, Franz.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Also die haben tatsächlich eine Cybercrime Unit.
Ost und West anscheinend auch noch.
Zudem gibt es schon irgendwie lange.
Ja, aber nicht in Deutschland, oder? Natürlich gibt es hier so etwas auch. Und wenn dann haben die keine Computer oder so was?
Natürlich gibt es hier so etwas auch. Es gibt da die entsprechenden Gruppen, die sich halt irgendwie mit solchen Sachen... In Holland hat sich halt vor kurzem irgendwie die Gesetzgebung auch halt nochmal verschärft. Wo halt diese ganze Abhörpflicht von Internet Service Providern irgendwie sichergeschrieben wird. Und das ist eben auch genau das Problem. Und das ist irgendwie ein paar Monate vor der Hell in Kraft getreten und wird natürlich irgendwie heftig kritisiert, weil es irgendwie unklar ist, welche Auswirkungen irgendwie das dann irgendwann nochmal haben kann. Weil es geht einfach nicht. Internet abschneiden, das sind einfach keine Methoden. Und diese permanente Abhörmanie der Stellen, die irgendwie in alles reinschauen wollen und irgendwie einem Kryptografie verbieten wollen und was nicht noch alles und sich dann irgendwie anmaßen. Sie könnten einem irgendwie die Kommunikation wegnehmen. Natürlich ist irgendwie diese Bedrohung da. Das merkt man ja ganz klar. Die haben halt irgendwie alle Schiss und die möchten ja gerne, dass alle irgendwie ihre Knowledge sharen und so weiter. Das ist ja alles ganz nice, was der Polizist da erzählt. Nur war das natürlich auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen das Damoklesschwert, was irgendwie über allem hing. Wir hatten das auf dem Kongress auch schon mal. Das ist irgendwie alles nicht so schön.
Ja, das ist ein blödes Skriptkit und die Holländerschaft.
Oder ein blöder Bulletsch.
Und ich meine, er hat halt irgendwie, Hacking ist not allowed in the Netherlands, was für ein Blödsinn. Das ist eben einfach die falsche Verständnisweise des Begriffs Hacking. Selbstverständliches Hacking erlaubt in Holland. Da können sie noch so viele Gesetze dagegen, irgendwelche Details erlassen. Es muss auch gehackt werden, zwar möglichst viel. Und irgendwie am besten noch ein bisschen mehr. Weil das einfach mal klare Fortbildung ist und weil dort irgendwie die Leute einfach auf Abenteuerreisen gehen und versuchen irgendwie die Dinge herauszufinden, die in dieser Welt verborgen sind.
Gehen unsere Bullen dann genauso offensiv damit um? Also stellen sie eben eine...
Die Gesetze sind halt noch nicht so verschärft.
Ich hab beim Camp vor zwei Jahren keine Rummellungen gesehen.
Die haben halt keine überraschenden Bändchen wie in Holland.
Ja, die waren alle hübsch markiert.
Echt? Ordner? Ja, wie war es denn sonst auf der Hall?
Es gab keine Ordner, da fing es schon mal an. Es gab keine Security um die 3000 Leute, also normalerweise bist du bei so einer Veranstaltung halt mit 40 Leuten groß, die schubsen die Leute und passen auf, dass da nichts passiert. Und das war hier nicht notwendig. Also es war eigentlich auch ein soziales Experiment und es hat voll geklappt. Es wurde nichts geklaut bei 3000 Leuten. Es lag alles auf den Rumm.
Ist nicht schlecht, hat beim Camp nicht funktioniert. Da sind ein paar über den Zaun gekommen damals.
Was?
Beim Camp Chaos Communication.
Ja, was hat das nicht funktioniert?
Security, also da sind irgendwie welche über den Zaun gekommen. Die haben es dann gekriegt wohl. Aber irgendwie, dass keiner was klauen wollte, das finde ich irgendwie ziemlich geil.
Nee, geklaut ist nichts geworden. Ich meine, es ist klar, dass bei so einer Veranstaltung nicht alle Leute irgendwie Eintritt zahlen. Das war irgendwie auch bei der Hell-Alles-Super-Relax. Es gab da irgendwie noch nicht mal eine richtige Eingangssituation, die irgendwie zwingend gewesen wäre, an der Kasse vorbeizugehen. Man konnte sich also genauso gut auf den drei Tagen da irgendwie vergnügen. Die haben zwar sicherlich hier und da mal nachgeschaut, aber das große Problem war, es hat tierisch gegossen. Die drei Tage, da war nur einer halbwegs trocken und der Rest war ziemlich verregnet. Das war schon ein bisschen bitter. Man brauchte halt irgendwie ein bisschen Raum, um sich da zu entfalten. Ich meine, man konnte ganz gut in seinem Zelt hängen. Das Radio irgendwie vom Kölner CCC und den anderen Aktivisten, die dort noch waren, und ein paar andere Stationen in die Media und was nicht alles. Oder man trieb sich halt in den Veranstaltungshelden rum oder in den Veranstaltungsräumen. Aber es war halt schon mal wieder sehr interessant, Leute aus aller Welt einfach prima zu treffen.
Wann gibt es das nächste Mal? In vier Jahren wieder. In vier Jahren wieder. Plant ihr noch mal ein Camp? Jetzt geht wieder das große Gelächter los, aber fragen kann man ja mal.
Wir finden uns in einem konstanten Friedengewicht.
Ich sag ja, das große Gelächter geht los. Das war's, wir müssen gehen. Chaosradio 64 auf Fritz. In sechs Minuten ist es ganz vorbei. Bis dahin hören wir uns noch mal den Remix von diesem Holländer an. Das ist doch mal eine schöne Sache. Ab eins gibt es hier den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Es bleibt wieder nichts anderes übrig, als Tschüss zu sagen.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB, produziert in Babelsberg.